They give it to him?
No,
no.
Half light cotton.
The best jeans I've ever worn.
I don't get paid for him.
The guy just said,
we live who live ladies and
mother fucking gentlemen.
This is a fight companion podcast.
What that means is we're
watching the fights.
This was supposed to be the heavyweight
title fight and I was supposed to be in
Vegas.
It's supposed to be for BC over
doom versus Cain Velasquez.
But Cain Velasquez got hurt.
Uh,
and he pulled out of the fight and
then steep meo chick replaced him.
And then [inaudible] said,
well I'm hurt too.
Fuck this.
And he pulled out,
cause I guess he had a couple of injuries.
Smart move.
I guess if you're injured,
you know,
he figured,
fuck it.
I'm just going to fight
cane no matter what I guess.
And then when,
um,
when he found out I
was Mijo chickies like,
listen,
I'm hurt.
Fuck this smart move.
Yeah,
because usually you do it.
This is before we go ahead and have it,
this,
this is a fight companion
podcast is not a regular podcast.
So we're watching the fights.
But honestly,
it's almost never us watching the fights.
So if you listen to this right now,
you're like,
I don't give a fuck about fights.
Most of the time we don't either.
Any Bravo's here?
My brother Eddie Bravo,
the greatest endeavor did it.
What?
Holla.
Brian Cowen,
my dog,
one of my favorite human beings on the
planet as well as my brother Brendan
Shop.
Also one of my favorite
humans on the planet.
So these are my favorite
podcast more than anything.
I look forward to these
fucking things the best.
There's so much fun.
The best.
It's like we get to hang
out and be ourselves.
We get to fuck around.
Just talk level dude's Oh,
just talking shit.
We get tell bro out.
We just throw out for three hours,
go out on a Pearl authentically,
have some fun,
watch some fights.
Talk about what we,
Brian is going to try
on this barbell jeans.
I got him some flexi jeans.
It's kids funny how guys
don't change my son.
I went hiking with him and all he was
talking about for two days is I want you
to teach me how to chop down a tree.
He's obsessed.
I'm like,
all right,
it was,
but I need to chop a tree down and
constantly go and we call it quote unquote
tropic tree none.
And I get him a hatchet.
He hasn't put that hatchet down.
You give that kid any kind of a weapon.
My daughter looks at the hatchet like,
what is going to,
maybe I can decorate it.
She wanted to know.
She wanted to put sparkles on the handle.
And my son was like,
why?
You know what's interesting?
You say gay men can go one of two ways.
They can go towards like girly type
stuff or they can go just as manly.
We talked about how to be assigned,
talking about the beers.
Well there's just not even know.
It's like two different styles of gay men.
Like I've a gay couple that
lives on my street stud.
Nicest fucking dudes.
There's so nice.
And one of them is the man.
Yes,
he's into trucks.
Yup.
And,
and,
and it makes all the cash.
You can break it down to one,
one to be talked trucks.
You can break it down.
One Guy,
one fox guys and the other doesn't,
well I don't know.
I don't know how that works.
I don't get personal with them.
They're just the coolest motherfucker.
It'd be the best neighbors.
I know.
Come to wipe that and I
get personal with them.
But then there's,
then there's like the
twinks who are there.
They're super girly.
Then why would you want
to just be with a girl?
You know what I'm saying?
Or like the lesbians.
Well how come some dude's like girls?
A big acid.
Some,
some girls,
dude's like girls are really skinny.
Everyone likes a girl with a big band.
Like there's some guys that are
into like really skinny girls,
like really skinny model
type girls with no acid.
I none of my friends,
it's all over the map that
it's a good way to put it.
It's all over the map.
He said the truck tried to
talk fucking suspension shit.
My heart,
John,
see you later.
He goes,
sucks days.
Husband is actually in the trucks too,
so it's weird.
But the point being is like,
they're very different
personalities that are gay.
Like I know gay dudes that
don't seem even a little gay.
And then,
you know,
they had eventually come out and it,
explain the whole thing like a,
do you know why?
Like this is like the fuck's his name.
Like,
let me think of like a good example
what this just so there's a lot of,
there's a lot to name him.
My Buddy,
my buddy Keith is,
is,
he's the man in the
relationship and he wrestled a,
you know,
and,
and college made millet makes millions
of dollars and he was with a bunch of
straight guys were all eating and
stuff hanging out that frank was there.
And he goes,
um,
he just said it.
So matter of fact that he goes,
man,
I think the only difference between
me and you guys is I suck cock.
You know,
it's got a really deep voice differences.
I'm not going to get fucked,
you know,
but I mean,
I fuck him.
You know,
that's Hilarious Guy,
right?
Some will only fund my
buddy Keith is that way.
Some will only fuck some of them.
Don't give blowjobs write up.
Some don't get blowjobs only
give blowjobs gay singles sites.
I bet they have to say that at that bit.
There's a name for that,
like a duty doesn't Suck Dick.
He's got to have a name.
There's gotta be like a code while
he's a think of a name.
I had the weirdest conversation with a
gay couple wants after a show I did in
Connecticut way back in the day.
Man,
I don't even remember what bid it was.
They were upset about,
but they came up to me after the show
and they were saying that they just,
just to let you know,
most gay guys don't fuck
each other in the ass.
Like we're married,
we're gay or there are a cop.
I don't know if they were,
it was legal to be married back then
because you're talking about like 91 92
something like that.
Yeah,
and he was talking about we just
blow each other when I was like,
okay,
I know where to go with this.
Was talking to me about
after a while I would,
I been,
I said,
I would've said,
I don't believe you,
but no,
no,
no.
He was,
he was being honest.
He was like,
we're not into it.
And he's like,
it seems like the kind of humor like that
kind of gay humor like fucking the ass
humor is like,
it goes over really big
out here in Connecticut.
Like,
but we mostly we hang out in the city.
Like he was one of those guys.
It was like big on telling you that.
I'm,
I'm very sophisticated.
I'm always in the city and I
don't even take it in the ass.
I'm just getting my dick sucked by guys.
This trained just fucking
conversation that guys like that,
that,
uh,
I went to him was,
it was like,
but you know,
guys do get fucked in the ass.
Yeah.
What I'm talking about someone
fucking some of the ass.
It's not like I'm making things up now.
No,
I was under the impression
that they all did that.
They don't,
they definitely don't.
They definitely don't option though,
right?
Yeah.
The first time,
I don't know.
I don't at least on their birthday
every now and then on the birthday,
boom,
you got to give up.
You know what I mean?
I'm having him do a
survey once in a while.
A complaint.
I bet that's the number one complaint.
That's why they,
they break up when that,
when they stop fucking in the ass and
it's just hand jobs that you know it's
over.
Yeah.
Fuck out.
Get the fuck out.
This is the kind of fight shot
Mike piles about the fights.
Sean's man.
How's the kind of fight that makes me
wish that TRT was legal cause pile so
fucking smart and exactly.
He's so fucking smart and crafty.
I wish they could get that dude on TRT.
You know what I'm saying?
100% needs it.
Well of course you definitely
need it when you hit for so long.
40 and think how long he's been fighting.
He's been fighting for a long
time and he's taken some,
some hard shots.
He's been Kod by guys like Matt Brown.
Tough.
He's been killed by Roy McDonald.
A few other guys too.
He's a tough fucking smart dude though.
He's his skill levels very high,
but you know there's a reality.
This is a goddamn difference
between a 21 year old body,
a natural one and a
natural 40 year old body.
They're just his,
his fight Iq is half the very highest,
very high.
He's a savage man.
About 10 years ago we did a movie together
were extras and it will be called a
the assassination of a
high school principal.
We play like I'm 35 years old and I'm
playing a fraternity guy and it was
terrible.
It was terrible.
So,
but we're both in it and I,
that guy is such a savage,
I've never seen anybody.
We went to a club that night.
Afterwards he went into a club,
grab a girl like a savage,
just Tucker grabbed that
bitch by the opponent down.
We went back to the hotel
and he handled business.
I never seen,
damn,
we don't know what his status was that
we don't know what happened between 10
and 20 years ago.
He could have been a hundred years ago.
Mike Pyle is,
one thing I remember about
Mike is he is a savage.
I've never seen anybody get down like
let's be real careful with those kinds of
details.
Those can be brought up.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's assault brother.
He can't be doing that.
Well he's uh,
yeah.
You can't say you do that anymore.
It used to be that that was
like an old movie trick.
Do you know who's the biggest savage as
far as getting chicks I've ever seen and
you would never guess want
to give you a hundred tries.
Me and him were in Toronto.
Give you a hundred tries.
Jake shields,
so I would imagine just Asian.
So he's a handsome Asian girls.
He's doing something you thought
he's Tom Cruise up in that bitch.
They scheels a very handsome guy.
I mean he's cool,
but he was like,
Hey,
I need you to be my wing
man and help me out here.
I was like,
what do you mean be?
Say it's cool.
Like you don't think
that's a good looking guys,
not Luke Rockhold Oh,
come
on.
I wouldn't say,
is that handsome there?
I said,
oh,
he's not as hands on with Luke.
Rockhold is ridiculous.
The time piece.
He's a straight coupon level,
that's for sure.
And your bonds a straight model.
He's alive and he's talking about,
those guys will tell you know the story
about Alan's Siobhan had a big photo
shoot in New York City like
two weeks before his fight,
so he had a cut weight twice.
She cuts wait for his photo shoots.
He gets shredded for his photo shoots.
I talked to Kenny Johnson
about his wrestling coach.
Is Versace,
right?
Yeah.
He's got a big fucking campaign man.
He's going to make bank Dan.
He's a beautiful person and not just the
way he looks the most like it's a great
guy,
great guy.
His heart.
He's the sweetest guy and a young don fry.
He's such a nice guy,
like to train with and everything too.
He's so polite.
He's just a great guy.
Like Alan Jaeger.
Bands are salt of the earth.
I agree.
But anyway,
it doesn't get any better looking
bitch.
Jake shields is a mate that's strong.
Yeah,
he's a strong strong.
Can you help me out here?
I say,
Oh,
come on.
Come on,
take yourself.
I'll give you a hit of weed
out sambo five I'm now fears
don't hell critical to help.
He's a nine girls like fucked up years.
Curls like the giant,
like a guy who's been through some danger.
They don't like a guy who
was terrified of danger.
It's a natural instinctive reaction.
It's to protect your genetics.
A guy who has never experienced danger
may very well fall apart in the face of
danger.
So a guy who does crazy shit
like does flips in bikes.
Why do you think they do that?
They do that because it attracts females
because females are attracted to a guy
who's very risky.
The guy who takes chances and does nutty
shit because those guys can survive
pressure.
That makes sense.
I'm just saying with all the UFC fighters,
I'd give myself a five because we're all,
you know,
we're all [inaudible] be a solid eight.
Yeah,
about that.
[inaudible] saw an eight
maybe eight and a half,
but you're better.
You're,
you're a notch better than Jake shields.
Cause you're way bigger than them.
Like I see girls look at you.
It's hilarious.
It's,
I'm looking at in their
little ovaries go hungry eyes.
Oh Shit.
Every parents,
everything we've done,
not just fighter and the kid fence.
My,
a friend of mine,
he's never even met shop before.
It was like,
who is your friend?
If you could tell her a little loins were
tender at the comedy store,
a bartender comments are
accountable now till fucking bro.
That's awesome.
Oh my gosh.
See I was already talking about her.
I'm just saying general mother fucker,
the waitress at the,
uh,
the waiters [inaudible] one of
the waitresses at the cottonwood.
How about nothing?
I would say,
what's a 10 Jovan?
He's up there.
Saatchi not lesson.
Well,
you're being kind of chops
and a good looking at,
he's got personality.
Personality means more than two points.
It does an eight.
Look at that.
Alan Japan.
Lord,
that's not even a real person.
Tell me he should at least tell me.
It's five [inaudible] eight tall,
six feet.
He just did the campaign for an equinox.
Alan Joe Ban Hater.
You fucking hate people because he's
one of the best people I've ever met.
I agree.
Just a great,
great dude.
It's fucking great guy.
Can't say anything bad about them.
If I look like that,
I'd wake up every morning and be like,
this going to be a good day.
I'm telling you though.
I mean he's not a pretty boy.
I mean this mother fuckers and scrap
some serious fights and he bites down on
that mouthpiece.
Very good fighter.
He fought to men off man to man off
is a mother fucker dude motherfucker.
I just liked that match up.
His efficiency and his stroke
is a tough fight for anybody.
Especially tough fight when you start.
He cut week two weeks but no,
he got knocked out in the first round.
No,
no,
no.
I'm saying not the result.
I'm saying on paper.
That's a tough fight to pick.
I wouldn't have taken it and if I,
if I was in there,
if I'm Joe man and I just
[inaudible] I wouldn't have taken it.
I wouldn't have taken it
because I don't think,
it's not that.
I don't think he could beat that guy.
I just think right now men off striking
is so smooth and efficient and heavy and
down the pipe string.
It's also very fluid.
Like he can go from throwing a jab to
throw in a lead up or cut in a straight
right hand and every one of
them is perfect and they count,
they count,
they're accurate and the mechanics
behind them are totally Crary.
Dude.
Like there's guys that
probably hit harder.
Like Tyron Woodley probably
hits harder than anybody.
Tyron Woodley like one shot for one shot.
Like when when he KLJ heroin,
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
he doesn't explode.
Exploder dude,
if he catches you perfectly
on that explosion,
he's going to put you away.
And it's not saying that like his
efficiency is bad cause efficiencies way
better even now because he's training
with Duke Roufus but to Nofx doesn't have
that one shot power that Woodley has,
but his efficiency is perfect.
Everything is perfect.
You see a guy that hits hard,
one of the things you see
almost invariably is there.
Their body positioning is always perfect.
Like when when a guy's throwing
like a ridiculous punch,
you'll see the bend in the legs,
you'll see the term body.
You know when a guy's like a serious
power Stryker with two Manav,
everything's in place.
It's all like the knees in the right spot.
When the hook,
when he's throwing the hook,
his foot's in the right spots,
waits in the right spot.
There's no like,
no bullshit.
Then he'd come out of the
Russian amateur boxing his thing.
He's a master of sports and boxing.
They keep fucking kicked too,
man.
He can Kish there was amazing.
Here's a program.
Yeah,
it's,
he's unexpectedly
dangerous with his kicks,
but he lost his last fight.
I didn't know.
No,
he beat a lark and that's right.
But it wasn't a great course.
It wasn't a great fight.
I love that fight really so close
because they're so dangerous.
We do a fight campaigning for that.
I don't think so.
This was the one with Lorens.
Lark was throwing those wheel kits.
That's right.
And Feminine Up is fucked up,
but to Nauv hung in there to the
end and one is super close fight.
I honestly thought that
Larkin pulled it off,
but I wasn't upset at the
decisions are so close.
It's so weird.
Those does low.
We'll kicks.
He does all kinds of weird,
skewed is a bad mother fucker dude.
He's one of the dark
horses in that division.
His take down defense.
I'm till I haven't seen
anything like in a long time.
He came up to rain to train with Munios.
Pat comes and myself
and his wrestling day.
I was like,
oh,
we're just going to take this full down.
Well I don't want to take it up by really
large was going to have the Kiki and
advantage in two minutes.
It's going to have the striking
advantage and that's how it turned out.
But God damn was a close ass fight.
Laura Larkin actually has braces and
during the fight is fucking braces were
sticking into his mouth.
Oh my God.
If something went wrong with his braces,
he was like trying to
fix it in between rounds.
Fucking Ufo with brace.
He shouldn't be fighting with braces or
Invisalign and he's very good looking
man.
He is the frank shamrock
racist and needs him.
The silver mouth,
I don't know.
I didn't see it until a,
they're talking about
an in between rounds.
The corner.
I still feel bad about
myself after seeing has got,
I wonder if Bella tours getting let
Benson Henderson fight with a toothpick in
his mouth.
Three of them do whatever
the fuck he wants.
He's going,
Oh shit.
Oh,
he's covering heads up really bad.
he's come on pile.
Don't get too crazy.
Oh,
it's three Oh one right now.
Three two 59 to 58 to 57 St.
That shit up a Mike Pyle
versus John Spencer.
Is that is fighting?
Is that the uh,
just got stocks.
Spencer got rock.
Is it?
Oh,
his name.
We shouldn't say that's his name.
[inaudible] oh shit.
Um,
Ben Henderson's fighting for
already for the title shot.
Right.
And he fighting Brooks.
Do you know that's like secretly my
biggest fear is he going to fight for the
title?
It's next month.
My biggest fear is for getting what
someone's name is in the middle of the
fight.
We'll calling the five cat.
Good thing you don't have the headroom.
How you doing?
Good thing dark.
I have Alpha brain and notes.
You got enough for
preying on you right now.
I could use some of that right now.
Um,
where's the chug?
It should be a jug of it.
Yeah,
there it is.
Good fights tonight man.
The best stuff is the,
the new stuff.
We have an instance.
The Shit I take for instance,
stuff is awesome.
I love from happening here too,
that Kyle Kingsbury on the other day,
he's the best great guy.
Oh my God.
What a sweetheart.
So fucking smart to his
wife is a smoke show.
3002 she used to be UFC ring card.
Yes.
It's very cool chick to
like real whole family.
Just good people.
They're,
they're salted.
The earth.
What'd you call so cool.
Salt of the earth dams.
I said smoke show.
Oh smoke show.
Salto their smoke show.
Um,
mine.
Mine's more old school.
You're just probably better.
Yeah,
she's just really sweet person too.
It's cool seeing them parents too.
It's wild because they have to or no one,
one little boy.
God,
he's so fucking cute.
You just start smoking weed like recently,
right?
And kind of like a,
I don't think so.
No,
no.
He does everything.
He's big in the IOWASCA.
Thomas was like,
shit,
I was under the impression.
Just started.
What do you mean like,
or maybe it's the week
before he did a bunch of uh,
Wasco and then flop pat.
Oh yeah.
Molly walked by Pat I had is a mother
corner pattern that fight pat Cummings is
a motherfucker.
Look how smart Mike Pilot.
It's like Oh,
efficient and smooth,
you know,
sees the shots he slips him like,
and he's in real good shape.
I mean don't get me wrong,
but that's just a reality about what a
40 year old body can do as far as the way
he pushes himself.
Like that was what recovery and
stuff are Nard Hopkins back.
You know,
like Bernard Hopkins just couldn't keep
a pace with a guy like surrogate Kovalev
off.
Like he had to go and do like
a defensive mode against him.
It was tough to watch,
but it was because he was 49 years old.
If he fought Kovalev
when he was 35 Holy Shit.
That would have been an amazing fight.
Fight,
amaze.
You see Cole of less white dude.
What the fuck?
He's a murderer.
Him and at him and Andre Ward.
That's the fight.
He killed the guy in the ring.
Yeah,
he did.
And it didn't kill the guy.
Yeah.
It didn't affect him the
way it affects most people.
It's very interesting.
I get it hurted Russia.
Yeah.
It didn't take anything off of his
desire to compete does not give a fuck.
He,
that's a,
that's one thing that happens
to fight or sometimes and man,
they're,
they're rarely the same
after someone dies.
Zany.
That happened.
He was never really the smell Griffith.
They say that,
that uh,
you know,
Emil Griffith's they say was
gay and that Benny Perez,
the guy who was fighting was talking to
a lot of shit about him being gay and
was saying a lot of like gay slurs and
Ameel Griffith beat the fuck out of that
dude.
I mean,
he died,
he died him to death.
They beat him to death.
Yeah.
I don't remember what round was.
If I went,
if I had a guest,
I want to say it was like the 14th round,
there's a documentary on boom,
boom.
Saying how when that guy died,
he was never the same.
Oh yeah,
of course.
He didn't want to find fighters and by
I think the guy's name is bond key moon
or something like that.
Cool.
Kim Duck who came,
that's what I was packing.
My boy you were close by king man is he
works as the is I think it's the correct
number,
the UN or something.
Um,
he was,
um,
his dad was his,
uh,
his dad was his coach.
Boom.
I know.
Uh Oh Jesus Christ.
Summer man.
Well that was another extreme.
Dehydration fight.
Extremely dehydrated.
You get down to one 35.
[inaudible]
shit was on national TV.
He also had weigh ins
the day of the fights.
It's a terrible idea.
They did.
Somebody did something I read
and I don't know if it's true,
but they said that pretty sure I remember
a number of people who've died in the
ring had dad's for their coach,
you know,
don't push themselves.
They're not a lot.
But apparently that's,
it's very common for guys
to push themselves to,
they get really hurt because
their dad's in the corner.
Well,
Wonderboy Thompson is trained by his dad,
isn't he?
Yeah,
yeah,
that's right.
And so sage,
sage,
Northcutts Dad,
um,
he's been Darren Cruickshank
trained by his dad.
You think sage is,
uh,
all the,
all the flak he's getting
on the Internet is just,
what do you think about that?
No,
listen,
I think like if you ask any fighter,
hey,
if Dane off do you 1440
going to take it at 19.
Fuck yes.
It's not his fault.
This whole hype machine.
Well you know what man,
it's uh,
it was a good fight for him to experience,
to learn.
That's all he needs to learn some,
you know,
some ground defense and he
needs to learn some Jujitsu,
but that's to be expected.
He's only fucking 19 years old Jim.
All the top guys that are good at you get,
I get caught.
I think it was the best
thing to happen to.
Sky's the limit though as far as he's
essential at 19 years of agency to have a
very good attitude.
He's a smart kid at like athletically.
He's ridiculous.
Fucking,
if you see those flush front flips,
it's crazy.
Off One off the toe off one
toe on the way he does it.
It looks like it looks fake.
It looks like he's on a stick.
You're spinning.
I'm like one of those uh,
foosball tables.
Yeah.
He said he was on antibiotics too in
that fight cause he looked like shit.
I mean we had strep.
It was one of the reasons why apparently
he tapped so quickly cause like when it
was clamping on his throat,
he was already swollen.
His throat was already fucked up.
He had strep.
He's going to be fine.
He gets a lot of,
hey,
it's a lot of head.
Of course it's tough.
Like,
uh,
like you see Tony Ferguson made a video
videos like I tapped out like a bitch.
It's tough if you're a guy like
Tony Ferguson who's grinding,
right,
he doesn't get nowhere near as much love.
Well like sage,
you know,
Tony Ferguson is in the PR business
as well as in the fight business.
That's the reality and
the post McGregor error.
You're in the PR business,
man.
Look what Conor Mcgregor did.
He's a,
Ooh,
my pile.
Got a good gay teens.
Got An Amo scooting in here.
Look at,
I'm scooting in here.
Watch that.
Right Butterfly.
He will mount.
He will fucking,
aw,
you missed it.
Missed the mount.
It was smart.
Bloody wrapping it all.
Yeah.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Mike Pyle,
he fought rampage Jackson
like in 2013 pro fights.
It was his first pro fight was
rampage Jackson in Tennessee.
Rampage is way bigger than he is.
Yup.
I'm telling you Mike Pyle and that was
one of the reasons that Matt Brown was
like so respectful about
him after the fight.
He's like,
people don't know how good Mike Pyle is.
I guess in the training room too.
He's even better.
I guess he's up mother fucker right here.
They say in the train room,
he's like unstoppable telling the TRT
is designed for dudes like this can't do
it anymore and now they have fun.
They have testing rates.
Yes.
They have a testing HGH that
gets you from 21 days out.
Why tell you're really fun.
It used to be like a day.
How do they to be like
24 I do shit anymore.
Can't do shit.
Gene doping be,
well,
I told you Novitsky said that they've
already at least theoretically have
testosterone that's derived from
animals instead of wild yams.
So the carbon isotope tests hasn't work.
Yeah,
it looks like human testosterone.
Wow.
Dirty bird shit.
Your names the dirty bird.
Yeah,
but it does of course
Mike Pyle,
Shawn Spencer throwing down man,
props to Spencer for surviving that.
That exchange just fights in Vegas.
Yeah.
This is at the
[inaudible] stadium.
Looks empty.
It's empty.
But I'm sure when the
main event dropped out,
I'm sure a lot of people
canceled their trips,
do it.
I'm not mad at for doom.
I was gonna tell you
about at the beginning.
Yeah,
it makes sense because since
he's the heavyweight champ,
the way it works out a lot of times is
you get a percentage of paper views,
but you have to hit a certain number.
Right.
It's hard to market steep a
verse for Doom on two weeks.
Yeah.
He's not going to hit those papers.
You numbers.
So when he was like,
oh,
I'm out.
I was like,
that's fucking brilliant.
But he's definitely hurt.
I'm the word that I'm hearing from
everybody said he's fucking hurt and he's
out.
He's been having some back
problems for a while now.
Apparently he was having it on
one side of his back and uh,
it would lock up,
but he was working through it and he,
Oh shit.
Oh Shit.
He got some
shit.
Ow.
Stop it.
Oh.
Oh Man.
John Spencer's,
who's the RAF is that you
stop loving son.
That's a brutal pile.
Just looked at him.
Stop it.
[inaudible] he's not defending himself.
Eve Levine let shit who Talla is,
but you keep that was,
that was not good.
I agree.
But you don't,
if you've got eve Levina as your rep,
you're like,
oh,
I'm about to get you fucked up.
It's a violent sport.
It is about to happen.
Yeah,
but we can prevent bad.
He doesn't know what five of those
shots and some of that pressure,
dude,
four or five of those shots,
he's been a ref for fucking the pressures.
If he would have stopped it
early and everyone found no,
no,
no.
What he gave a fuck.
That guy was out.
I guys in trouble rather have it go a
little late then we'll know that hurts the
sport.
My man,
that's,
that's a hurdle.
Fucking sport.
I disagree.
How is that hurting the sport?
Are you getting paid little violence?
Yeah,
but a little late is unnecessary.
That wasn't that late man.
That was a very entertaining,
I might be one last fight on
[inaudible] is what we pay for theirs.
You know what?
It's real subjective Eddie cause
you're right in a lot of ways.
But then again like there's guys
that survive it like Frankie Edgar,
right?
If you stopped every fight with Frankie,
Edgar was wobbled,
you'd be in jail.
I mean he would never be gray Maynard
and that second fight by Kao Cause he got
hurt hard in that first round
and a lot of trigger happy would,
would've pulled the trigger on that fight.
And there's a shitload
of fights like that.
There was a whole list of them.
But this one,
this one is prolonged would,
this is my problem with this.
He's not hitting back and
he's not defending him.
How's he going to win?
He's not doing anything.
He's just taking shots.
He's not [inaudible],
but
those last shots,
he's not moving.
He's not moving at all.
He's just surviving on its [inaudible].
Celebrity Rehab was definitive call.
It wasn't on the fence.
It's not because a little over the fence.
That's why there's subjective thinking,
dude,
how different different points of view.
But you know,
I see your argument.
Well,
we got to realize why
are we watching this?
We're watching,
we're watching this for brutality.
Right,
but you got to protect the guy when the
highlights or I'll buy it from his own
timeline.
That's a beautiful highlight.
Highlight,
highlight,
highlight.
If you stopped it,
three punches before it still highlight.
Yes,
I agree.
I agree to take on to,
but it's not the worst.
That was up the worst dot.
Oh,
not at all.
Like you know what's worse?
You know what was worse?
Rockhold and Chris Weidman,
100% was worse.
It was a site that should have been
stopped 100% when they weren't.
When he was on top of them.
I was saying,
what does Luke Rockhold have
to do to get a stoppage?
Cause this is a,
this is terrible.
Like Chris Weidman is taken damaged.
It's unnecessary.
I'm not just unnecessary,
but most likely when you
take get beaten up like that,
you're not going to recover.
But really there've been many,
many fights where they could have easily
stopped it and the guy came back to
rock cars are loud.
Yes,
Joe.
There's a lot of fights like that.
You got to let it go for
the fans and pisses depends.
65 fucking dollars now come on.
We don't want,
we'd rather have them
be taken serious early,
late low.
Early is always going to win.
I think Brock Lesnar Brock Lesnar looked
better versus Shane carbon didn't.
Weidman did.
Oh hundred percent there
really wasn't any damage.
Right.
He's getting hit but covering up,
but there's no blood.
But he was,
he looked like he was there.
Yes,
he Weidman was calling.
Thumped on face was literally like
someone shot him with the greatest moments
and made a bunch of
peanuts because of that.
That's why the fuck,
that's why.
That's why hardly nobody's doing MMA.
Cause did the brutality.
That's why.
That's why people are paying $65 for it.
If it was all decisions,
no one would pay for anything.
If it was a scroll that regardless,
that wasn't that bad.
We don't have to argue about it.
I see Eddie's point of view and I,
I'm,
I'm leaning more towards your side.
I think maybe it could have stopped it
because you're just standing there taking
shots.
He wasn't moving.
No head trauma guys just stand there
taking shots and he's not moving.
He's waiting for the referee stopped.
He was standing fully erect.
He wasn't walking
stud.
He's a stud.
He's in excellent shape but
that's how a lot of guys die.
Like a lot of the guys that
have died from getting beat up,
they didn't go down.
They got beaten down.
They sank into the ropes.
How many people have died in MMA?
5,000 about MMA mostly,
but boxing,
mostly boxing.
Well you know,
one of the things that MMA has going
for it is that you could fucking clinch,
it's the cruelest shit ever to watch.
A guy like rocked in a boxing match and
the referees like pulling them off and
holding onto the guy.
The only thing that's keeping that guy,
that's the only thing keeping them alive.
They're like,
nope,
you can't hang on.
They're going to break up.
Break it up.
You're like,
oh no.
If you don't let go,
I'm going to disqualify you.
Oh Shit.
It's the worst.
It's really dumb.
Mike Pyle,
powerful Mike Pyle is a big win for him.
Congratulations to him.
He's been fighting for ever man.
40 years old.
I remember the first time I
heard his name Ed clay fit.
There's a guy from Tennessee,
may,
Mike Pyle,
he trains at my gym.
Watch out for this guy.
This is 2001 or 2000 so long ago.
He's 40 now.
It's crazy.
No taller than head.
I think MMA in a way has a longer
lifespan regardless of what you're taking.
Even if you're taking nothing,
then boxing desk cause it's not as
completely dependent upon reflexes.
There's so many different skills to learn.
Oh Man.
Yeah,
it's trust is brutal.
See that's when he looked at the left.
Wait,
stop.
Stop.
Stop wanting to make sure it,
boom.
Okay,
we're done.
He's still on his feet.
Guy Wasn't doing shit though.
Shaun's was just taking it because I
didn't need to take that last name.
All right.
Violet.
Poor baby.
Rip His head off.
Eddie.
Eddie's die.
Rip His head off.
It wasn't the worst,
but just trying to be honest here.
That's it.
I'm just trying.
I,
I see what you're saying,
but poor baby
man.
This guys just fought.
It's harder like,
hey,
that's what,
that's what people are
paying $65 and they know the,
they know the game.
I don't know man.
I ain't know the game.
They know it's brutal.
Everybody's well aware
they're in a fucking cage,
man.
Dude,
you're throwing full blown
Shin kicks to your skull.
No one's trying to stop that.
That's what hurt.
They are trying to stop that.
That's the whole idea behind it.
What would you rather take?
What he went through against the fence
like that with those elbows like that and
you were kind of standing or Edson
Barboza just throwing a straight fucking
kicking your face.
That switch.
That switch kicked Kira
floating around on the switch.
I'm talking about,
I'm talking about the
wheel kick with the heel.
That'd be the hardest hit.
It doesn't feel good to take those
Mike Pyle elbow all definitely.
His fucking wheel kick is perfect.
His switch kick in his wheelchair
collect the best I've ever seen.
The fastest to eat.
His leg kicks are so God
damn fast and everything.
Barbels is probably the fastest
kicker maybe I've ever seen.
I think I've ever seen
anybody kick his fastest.
Him Not even close to,
I can't even think.
A lot of fucking chaos with those
wheel kicks over the last five years.
Look at Wonderboy Thompson common now.
Do you remember we used to talk about
it and I was like just people don't know
how to do it.
Yeah,
I go,
people know how to do it.
It's horrific.
Yup.
Because of it lands.
I'd never seen anybody get wheel kicked
in the head by a guy who is good and not
go out.
Like when you get healed,
when a heel hits your head,
sometimes you catch guys with
the toes and those guys are okay,
but you got to get slapped.
Yeah,
but when a heel hits you in the head
from a guy who really knows how you got
your boot on and you've got the bulldog,
Wonderboy landed.
No,
no,
no.
You had your boot on as
opposed to like this.
Well,
the,
the key is it's just
like throwing a punch.
The idea,
like when you throw in a punches,
you don't want your hand completely
clinched up until you're going to make
impact because then slows the punch down
so you're supposed to punch and then
tighten your hand up
as you're about to hit.
It's like kind of a timing thing and a
lot of ways you want to keep everything
as loose as possible while
exploding in the right way.
It's the same thing with a kick.
When you throw in that wheel kick,
you want everything to be almost like
ballet until like halfway there and then
halfway there you're pulling your leg
back and you pull it and you put in
pushing your foot forward and
you stick in that heel out.
But it doesn't come into like there.
It's like as you're in
the middle of the spin,
once you get like they're,
that's when everything
hardens up and boom,
and then you come across with
a heel that's of Barboza.
No MMA fighters.
We're working on that shit and
fuck me,
nobody was working on,
everyone is now though
did PBS to make fun of it.
She brought it up,
I would say,
you know like once people
learn how to really throw,
spinning back,
kick to the body,
I'm like,
it's like getting hit by a car.
It was more really when people,
when the people that
already know how to do it,
learn how to wrestle and did you get to,
so they're not afraid to throw it because
everybody that was karate guys and
taekwondo guys in those times,
but they were told by their MMA coach,
don't fucking throw that shit cause these,
these guys going to take
you down to choke you out.
So they were limited like,
okay,
we're going to keep it,
you know,
nice and simple and we're not going to
do the spin kicks that we know what to do
because we suck on the ground.
But once like Stephen
Thompson or Wonderboy,
Wonderboy Ellenberg he's
good on blue motherfucker.
Yeah,
you guys after it,
Helen Burger said that it was a
waste of time to throw those things.
He's like,
I'm not worried about is
spinning to said waste of time.
That's what he said.
He's like that's a waste of
energy in the bend of the review.
Did he really?
Not In the preview.
So Wonderboy moves like a fucking snake.
That's the future right there like that.
Like Conor Mcgregor,
like a Diego Brandao.
Those guys that just throw every opened.
That's Chris.
He throws a lot of fun.
It's a great striker,
isn't there?
I'm not going back to those to those
was a lot of spinning shit you throw,
they throw some wild meat
compared to as Joanne in the wild.
Did you ever,
did you ever throw spitting shit
and you know what I'm saying?
Never.
Never ever.
Why you're super athletic.
No one really taught me.
I never had,
I never had a kickboxing
coach or taekwondo coach.
No one ever said you should.
Every now and then it's good to have
a fucking game over game over a weapon
right there at said that we'll kick man.
It's no one ever told you that,
huh?
A lot of fighters though
or don't throw much.
Most I would say not 80%
still don't throw them right,
so a lot of them can't.
Totally project thing.
He's had to learn a lot of time on
that shit and it's not exactly if,
if you're putting it in,
you know what priorities put spinning
wheel kick number 30 is a long term
project for such a shit.
That's why it helps if you have a martial
arts background star with when you're
a kid,
you learn that shit first.
It becomes normal.
Like if you see a little four year olds
through onside kicks and then we'll
kicks.
It's hilarious and it's adorable
because their legs are so,
they're so used to throw their legs.
Yeah.
You know,
if they throw their legs up in the air
and it's normal and then as they get
older and their legs get heavy,
their body's used to the dynamic.
Habib number,
Madoff and Tony Ferguson,
Agler Hearns and chase.
Thank God he's going
to fight Johnson again.
I was like,
what the fuck is this?
Settle the fuck down.
What are the odds that that fight is
really gonna take place Xero to not
hurt all the time.
He's unfortunately,
he's super talented,
but he's hurt all the time.
He's going to get hurt again.
Get you could get hurt again easily.
You know what?
He's going to hurt the not,
I'd say.
Which sucks.
Yeah.
Look,
people get hurt,
so that's a,
there's a 50% chance of him getting
hurt or 80% let's say 60% that's a lot.
That's a Fox card apparent.
That's a lot on my calendar.
At least that's a Fox card.
I don't know if that's going
to be an fs one or Fox card.
I don't think it's a,
I don't think it's an Aka thing.
How have you guys are getting hurt?
I think Khabib and cane,
they just have so much experience with
wrestling and doing combat sports.
They're just getting up there,
man.
They trying to train like regular dudes
and they're getting hurt while the
people were like,
oh,
that's gay.
Habib's young guy.
He has a ton of experience.
Does wasn't,
they're world champions,
master of sports and it's
interesting because when it,
yeah,
just a wrestler and he
beat the brakes off though.
He looks like when you,
when you're watching them compete,
he looks like a wrestler.
His wrestling wrestling is
outstanding leg lock in people.
Not really smashing people on the ground.
Those guys,
those guys in Russia do a
lot of Greco too though.
When you're Samo guy,
you're also doing a
lot of Greco typically.
Well his,
his clinch is insane is a bit of ability
to control from the top is insane.
Well,
which was,
I was going to say about
Rockhold the other day.
It's two fights in a row.
Rockhold impressed me in a huge way with
his ability to control from the top we
against Machida and then against
Weidman cause Machida was impressive.
But I was like,
I think he had,
but she had a fucked up before they
went to the grounds of the temple thing.
But you don't want to the ground.
He destroyed them.
I think Maci was already fucked up,
but Weidman wasn't like,
why?
Why me?
He just caught a wheel kick in a fight
where there was real close fight.
But once he got him on the ground,
man,
God damn,
game two,
I think he's,
you know,
he's Wyman was walking around
it in one 93 apparently.
And I mean rock two weeks before the
fight with two 16 technique to his
technique is nasty.
You can't just say size sizes,
it's conditions,
obviously.
God,
he's also training with,
I don't know,
Daniel Cormier and came to Alaska.
I think that's a huge part of it,
man.
I think that's a huge part
of it because like Ledcor me,
he said when he fought John Jones,
he didn't have cane is corners that came
was all fucked up from surgery and he's
like,
I made a big impact on me.
I really felt it.
Whether or not that had anything to
do with him blues into Jon Jones.
You making that face or fights and I
want to see if any job I want to see
Anthony Johnson,
John Jones fight.
Oh yeah.
I want to see that too.
That's what I want to call me a,
uh,
I want to see him with cane in
his corner training with him,
see if that has any impact.
But I'd like to go going down,
right canes going through surgery.
Apparently it's going
to have back surgery.
Really?
He already had it.
Yeah.
You already had it.
He already had him.
What do you think about home and tape
that came back?
Surgeries?
Not An easy thing.
Like there's not like a small deal.
You're taking pieces of,
your disc is out for a
while at a diskectomy,
right?
Is that correct?
What does that mean?
That means the,
the Gel that separates your discs.
He had a piece of it removed because
it was pressing into his nerve.
She's,
it's very controversial procedure because
some people feel like you don't have
to do it.
Like Louie Simmons,
the guy from west side Barbell,
they uh,
wanted to take him and fuse his discs
and that's why he created that machine
that I have outback,
the hyper,
uh,
the uh,
back,
um,
the fuck's it called
reverse hyper reverse.
Reverse hyper.
Oh,
that's a big glass of
wine and not mad at that.
Want to try and get,
I hear setting that's trying
to get drums in the background.
My favorite county.
Right.
Tomahawks
brought the fire,
get involved in the case.
What do you do with Kane?
You got to be careful.
You got to rehab that back,
man.
I don't,
I'm not necessarily a big fan
of cutting your back right away.
I think you got to take some time off a
training and really heal that bitch up
correctly.
I'm pretty sure you already had surgery.
Here's my thoughts though.
If you want to get back
into it really quick,
that's the way to do it.
But longterm health,
I'm not entirely convinced I need,
Oh,
obviously I'm not a doctor,
but I've recovered from bulging discs.
I had a bulging disc in my back
that doesn't exist anymore.
And a bulging disc in my neck.
It doesn't exist anymore.
If you look at it on the Mri,
it looks different.
It's from long term Rehab.
I had to take a lot of time off a rolling.
I had to do spinal decompression with a,
I did it at a,
an an office with a chiropractor at
first and then I got some machines we can
strap them up,
some mechanical sheet.
You strap your door at your house.
I went through Regena keen injections.
I went through a lot of rolfing and uh,
like breaking apart scar tissue that
was pulling on everything and that
everything was all fucked
up and tightened up.
It was just like years and
years of wear and tear.
But now through that and through yoga,
I don't have any of those issues anymore.
They're gone.
So I don't know what his,
how bad his was,
but I know mine was,
my fucking hands were numb,
you know,
my left hand was going down my fingers,
my,
my two fingers,
my ring finger and my pinkie
finger were going numb.
So let me ask you this Joe,
what do you do with the
heavyweight division?
You have their doom fight.
A guy like Rothwell what cane
should concentrate on if I was cane,
I mean get your body
completely fucking healthy.
There's a lot of people that have like
severely criticized his strength and
conditioning videos that are online.
I don't know if he works
with this guy anymore,
but he was working with a guy that was
like the strength and conditioning coach
and he had him doing these,
you haven't seen this.
Oh my God.
Pull up.
Is He doing some bullshit?
Ain't oh yeah.
Pull up cane.
Uh,
does a 200 pound kettle bell swings.
His form is according to Steve Maxwell
and according to a bunch of other
respected Kettlebell trainers,
completely wrong,
and this guy's got him lifting this
insane weight and doing this completely
wrong.
Almost like a shrug.
He's 200 pounds.
Yeah,
I think it's more than 200.
I think it's 200 plus here is,
it's two or three pounds.
So this is his train and like
I'm telling you the reviews on,
on youtube by people that suited.
Know what the fuck they're talking about.
Like watch this.
He's training it looks like,
but look at this like what he's doing.
He's doing a shrug.
That's not a swing.
That's not as swinging on a swing.
Yeah.
No wonder you're back's fucked up.
You sir,
you can totally get fucked up doing this.
The fuck is that.
It's wrong.
And the guy had him doing leg extensions.
We'll look.
The guy's obviously a big fucking
guy himself and didn't mean shipping.
This is better than doing nothing.
Right?
You disagree,
but it's not optimal.
It's not the best.
He fighting
100% it's a big ass kettlebell.
Those bouncy balls that my son has.
Yeah man,
he's lost human as swinging and
then doing like an upright row row.
Yeah,
it's,
well it's a shrug.
It's like he swings,
he swings,
he gets to wear his dick is,
and then he showed a shitty shrug up row.
It's just fucking nother kettle
but not a kettle bell swing.
And it's probably not good for you.
It doesn't look right.
And Steve Maxwell was furious
when Steve Maxwell saw it.
He was like that.
That is,
that's like,
he was like almost
essentially calling you.
I'm like malpractice.
I told them I don't have a degree in it,
but that looks terrible.
So around the weight room I
entirely fucking terrible.
You got with Cain and you've
got to fucking super athlete.
A guy who just do what you tell him
and fucking push through everything.
Yeah.
And that's probably one of the
reasons why he's been injured.
It's cause he's pushed through some,
some pain that maybe
you should lay off of.
And I don't know.
Like what?
I mean,
maybe this can help me for him is perfect.
Maybe it's perfect.
Maybe it's a real simple thing like maybe
it's only sticking out a little bit on
one side.
If they trim it,
he'll be back to training four weeks.
I don't know.
But I know that for a lot
of people what you can,
you can get like real hasty and make a
decision to jump into surgery and it's
not the best decision,
but especially when there's
a lot of money on the line.
We have to fight though.
That's the thing for a lot of these guys.
Like they might have to fight in six
months so you'd have to get the surgery
because realistically with six months
of therapy you might not be ready again
yet.
Dude,
he has to fight before six months.
The heavyweight belts
on your wait six months.
Well,
if his health is on the line
and going flying arm triangle,
if his health is on the line,
man,
this guy's good man would wait.
Is this,
is this heavyweight two oh
five this is the main card.
No,
May,
yeah.
Mischka Serp Serp.
Cool.
KNAUF is Russian Guy Hop Russian dud
couple of one two bodies on them.
That was pretty brutal.
Good hair.
Good hair on that guy.
I'm just saying,
Joe,
you,
if he's out six months,
you're gonna have to have it.
Well,
you don't have the title,
the title,
you're going to have
somebody else buy a Rothwell.
Yeah.
He would do both of them in that time
that it takes him to realistically come
back.
Yes.
But he's got,
I don't Dunno.
He's got to be careful and he's just,
he's still fairly young.
I mean,
I think Keynes like what?
34 34 is a lot of experience.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it catches up,
but he could realistically fight at the
highest level for the next three years,
but these injuries,
wow.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
It's real controversial,
but in my experience,
talking to different doctors,
there's doctors that say she gets
surgery and there's doctors should say,
you should absolutely not concerned
scale until you've exhausted all the
options.
Yeah.
Either way.
Still in the grace of all
time heavyweights easily.
Well,
Jake shields,
they were telling him he was fucked.
What happened?
You're telling him he couldn't,
couldn't fight again.
You should stop training
started and he was really mad.
He's like,
he's fucking doctors are so negative
fan because first of all they're just
regular doctors.
Dee Dee used to dealing
with regular people.
Yeah.
A lot of them not you stealing with the
elite athletes and guys who are willing
to go through like the kind of rehab that
a guy like Jake shields is willing to
go through like some serious
fucking pain and discomfort.
But he got through it.
He's fighting now.
He just backed out of it.
Is fighting a world series.
Apparently it's a contract thing.
Yep.
Do you know the full details?
I don't.
Apparently what it is is it's,
it's a title fight.
So if he fights for the title because
Paul Harris got stripped this trip.
Paul Harris after the John Fitch fight.
Cause they say held it too long.
Right?
Was it a Fitch?
Fine.
I thought he know
his eyes.
Yeah.
Stripped him after that and then,
but here's the thing about that,
the eye gouge.
Like you either stop the fight
like while it's happening.
Yeah.
You don't let it go.
I can't see and then to to like to
a strip of afterwards for I gouges.
It's weird.
That's super unprecedented.
Well,
maybe they saw tape and realized he
was dragging his finger through it.
He was too.
He was hiding what he was doing.
It was different.
She'll just like,
yeah,
like transfer on midstream
oil and it was very evident.
Right.
Replay through one solid.
Yeah.
They're just like,
ah,
you're good.
Just keep on.
Keep on.
One's a cheater.
He was cheating.
He was definitely sticking
fingers in the eye.
That was a real bad guy.
What people got mad about was the Kimora.
He held the Camorra,
but I don't think that was
that bad because the referee
was in the wrong place.
The referee,
fuck,
don't look at it again.
He's tapping his back.
You're expecting him to
recognize that that's a referee.
Tapping is back in the middle
of a ferocious cage fight.
The referee supposed to be
in between the two of them.
He's supposed to stop it if it
was a normal guy known for it.
He's done it so often.
If it was a normal guy,
like if it was you,
if you had Mitch reone
in that same position,
you hit that Kamora and
you held it for that long.
Why the referee was tapping you.
I do not think you'd get
the same kind of grief.
I agree.
I think you would say I was
in the middle of the fight.
I didn't even realize referees tap me.
I didn't see him cause the
referees in the wrong place.
The referee in that position,
it's supposed to get in
between the fighters.
He supposed to be in front so
he could look him in the eye.
We'll pour Horace has that
Kimora he was out of place.
He was over here.
He's supposed to be over here.
What about Paul Harris
versus Gary telling him,
damn,
I love that.
Where's that taking preschool gangsters.
Gary telenet holds.
Explain to Gary.
Tony Blair,
I hope Carrie is a Jujitsu show,
the Jujitsu event held in England.
It's Kinda like metamorris.
They have a bunch of single matches
that are submission only and I think if
there's no submission it ends
up being a draw 20 minutes.
It's just like metamorris in that respect.
I think 1520 minutes.
I'm like that.
And they put on great shows,
great match ups and a man,
Gary Tonin is taken on.
I saw that.
That is so fucking gangster.
I agree with.
I saw scared wants to,
he's the only guy that's
asking for Paul Horez.
Nobody wants
Paul Harris.
Just in general buddy.
The last five guys that are far powers.
It's because they just,
they offered the fucking fight to
them and had no one's going after him,
you know,
and then just graphical Horace.
It's,
you know,
it's highly possible that he's
going to Eleague luck Paul Harris.
But it gives you an idea how good Jake
shields was because he was beating Paul
Harris up on the ground.
He was controlling his body.
He's unbelievable.
Hey Jake.
Jake shields is one of the past.
Hey tone in though,
when we saw him at your event,
I was,
yeah,
you were talking to of mirror last time
I saw something like a motherfucker.
He was eating these dudes up.
Well.
Then leg lock came that John Danaher,
her leg lock game is very high level man.
Him and Eddie,
Eddie Cummins,
the,
both of those guys are
fucking wizards man.
And Danaher apparently
is a wizard to like,
I never seen Donna her role,
but everybody says he's just,
he's sad.
He's so God damn smart and I'll start
it with dean lister Douglas or went to
[inaudible] in like late nineties 2000
2001 and dean lister came into the
Jujitsu world already as a sambal guy.
So he was always the guy,
even as a white belt,
as a blue belt in southern California.
Dean,
we grew up together,
Jujitsu.
He was always that leg lock dude,
that Samo guy who got into Jujitsu.
So that dude dean lister
goes on to win Abu Dhabi,
absolute leg lock and fuck and everybody
that knee bar that he hits Salo Roberto
with Holy Shit in 2003 watch
that shit to the knee bar.
He had solid Robero solar barrel
was like one of the best ever,
one of the greatest players ever.
And doing that.
That knee bar that he got him with was
Gary Tone and I don't want the current
rank are,
but as he number one,
he in person,
he might be the best I've ever seen
real official rankings because there's a
point,
there's a point game and then
there's a submission only game.
But,
but let me finish really quick.
So that guy,
dean lister,
he goes to Hem Zos and Danaher's there
Danaher's a a little prodigy and he
leaves an impression with a debt.
Danner,
I'm sure he left.
Uh,
he left a couple,
oh man,
he's fucked is Jello.
And the Danaher took what he learned from
Dean lister and he just blew that shit
up.
And Dan is like a scientist,
I think he's a physicist
or something or so rock.
Under Armour has her phd in
philosophy and something like that.
Philosophy and Houston,
hence I used to give him,
hence her back.
This is literally,
I don't know,
I've got 2003 or whatever.
Hansa when somebody come into kind of
challenge and somebody who's really good,
he would kind of casually give John,
he'd said,
roll with John for a while
and see how you do first.
And John would just,
you'd watch him tap these dudes like these
really good Samo guys or whoever they
were and he just,
just like,
he was moving in slow motion.
He's a minimalist,
right?
He's just really smart ones.
He was a builder or power lifter
and then just ridiculous as strong and
he wanted to learn martial arts to deal
with,
like in bouncing
situations,
he realized I should
probably have some skills.
That's insane.
Yeah.
I had no idea.
He doesn't look like it now,
but he's,
he's still obviously very strong.
If you look at him,
he's thick and fit,
but apparently he used to be like
really bad and my summer a UFC event,
he was like at the bar afterwards and
he had on a fucking rash guard and some
jeans tucked in.
No fucks given me.
These guys have Alzheimer's wedding.
That's his thing.
He was dead.
So gangster always salmon.
Her and I,
every time he wasn't stop foods.
Look,
he's created Eddie Cummings,
Gary Tonin,
because Gary Tonin went to hens,
owes to train with Danner and
he didn't have any leg locks.
He was all rear naked choke.
He had his,
you know,
basic.
He was already a black belt.
He went to Dan or that's when he started
learning the leg locks from him and
through Eddie Cummings.
They,
you know,
then him and Eddie come and just became
like best friends and training partners.
I was so impressed with Gary.
I took,
I took privates from John Donner.
Yes,
like probably five and that was,
I got this new guy,
Gordon Ryan who just got his black belt
is fucking amazing as well as the new
guy.
You're going to shuck corn.
She knows another leg
lock master the people.
Forget Dave Terrell.
You remember Dave to WRAL versus
Ricardo Almeida in 2003 in Abu Dhabi.
Don't remember that dude.
Dave Terrell had some nasty
ass fucking leg locks.
Dave Tarell was so explosive.
I've heard legendary stories
about him in the training room.
He's the best ever.
I saw it.
I was seeing him compete like
watching him and Abu Dhabi,
I always expected he was going to be
UFC champion because he went into MMA,
starts smashing people.
He knocked out Matt
Lindland at first round,
but Evan Tanner got him and he also had
a series of catastrophic ear injuries.
He had to have it removed from his head.
Why can't,
it's like staff inside
his head from his ear.
His ears were just Gonzo,
right?
They were like these just
fucking ash trays on his head.
Hard as a rock,
just all cauliflower.
Dot.
But apparently like just years and
years of hard training yet he got an
infection inside his ear and
they had to take it on his bike,
his whole fucking ear off his head,
clean it all out,
like try to fuse it and
swap it and cauterize it.
She get could get it to stop oozing,
pus you in,
your ear falls off and it didn't work.
They had to do it again like he's got he,
he went through like,
and like when your ears fucked.
Have you ever had an earache or can your,
your equilibrium's off?
You can't do shit or worse.
So he's like a mythical creature and uh,
nor nor cal two.
And there's so many crazy stories
about that guy who was Syme compete.
I was like,
that fucking guy moves like
a ghost as fast as fuck.
And his students,
uh,
one of them,
Joe Soto,
they're so good at leg lock defense.
when you're generally,
when you game plan against Eddie Cummings,
the game plan is stay away from any kind
of footsie battles you don't want to
battle was at.
Avoid it.
Try to do the,
the,
the Super Basic Jujitsu strategy.
Like what?
Uh,
um,
I think it was Lucas dupree
and Abu Dhabi did a Gary Tonin.
It was either Lucas
the pre or Leandra low.
I kicked those guys
mixed up all the time on,
well,
one of those guys that I will dobby when
against Gary Tonin and he just straight
knee slice,
boom.
Stayed tight,
stayed in side control,
top half tight.
Never let Gary get anywhere near his legs.
You know,
that's the game plan against a
leg lock guy like Eddie come.
That's it.
You try to play footsies with them,
you're,
you're retarded.
But Joe Soto,
he went in there in the finals,
that Ebi three,
he went in there and just said,
he sat on his ass and I'm
gonna play footsies with
Eddie comes and it wore for a
long time and everybody
was just blown away.
It's like,
how the fuck is he leaving his legs out
there for Eddie Cummins grafters legs
and Joe Soto just displayed
just this incredible,
uh,
of defense.
His leg lock defense.
I was reffing gone.
What the fuck dude?
Is He really playing?
Footsies with Eddie coming?
He ended up getting caught.
Eddie Cummins did catch him,
but he showed tremendous fucking savagery
for going in there and plan legs with
them.
And I talked to him
afterwards and he said,
dude,
I,
I roll with Dave Tarell all the Goddamn
time that guys always after our legs.
Are you kidding me?
We're used to this shit kill or
be killed if you're in a leg lock.
Speaking of submissions,
Cummings knees all fucked up.
How about your boy Rob
Barnett and Roswell?
And so it'll fuck called that insane,
insane.
Insane.
Apparently when Rothwell
gets a hold of your neck,
he just knows how to speak.
He was showing me what he got him in.
Oh,
that's horrible.
I don't know how his hands are though.
I don't know how he's gripping his hand.
I don't know it is either.
It's a 10 finger essentially,
but the coach wanted to call it a go.
Go choke hard because it,
it goes against your throat.
Sort of like a Google Plata or if
there's no one hot on the UFC division
heavyweight division right now,
then no Rothwell's the police.
He's the beast.
You'd like being that guy right now.
Their confidence.
He pays the bees too though.
It's like it's real close like well
after Steve Bay destroyed Orlowski like
that.
Steve Bay's right in there.
Man will face Mickey Gal.
It is year apparently one earlier
tonight he did and he's a,
I was hearing a lot of
criticisms about a face off.
Cm punk walked in.
It was the first prelim
ever to have a face off.
I just feel like,
I don't know why he would want to do that.
I feel like if he was smart he
would just start fighting and small
organizations,
you know,
I get that you want to get a lot of money
because I'm the UFC is where it's at
with money.
But I would think like the smart move
is what he's already done training wise.
Go to a real camp.
He goes to Rufus,
perfect roof is going
to teach him how to uh,
strike as good as anybody in the world.
Agree.
And then you got real good
wrestling with Ben Aspirin.
You got a real good Jujitsu,
you got everything there,
everything,
everything there.
I heard they offered him,
I heard they offered him and go
through the tough show and he's like,
Nah man,
I'm trying to write to the shell.
So I think tough would
have been better for them.
You get ratings.
We see how he does.
He gets warm up and then,
you know,
then he goes,
but for your first fight
to be in that octagon,
good fucking who was
Mickey gauzy tough though?
Well,
he's a newcomer.
They found them on that looking for a
fight show on HBO and a small show or in a
youtube rather in a small organization.
We are looking for it.
He's a,
he's a brown belt brown belt.
Significant that.
That's what I read earlier
today after he won,
he won by submission.
They said he was a brown.
I heard,
I heard blue and purple.
The UFC said brown belt,
so I don't know.
Okay,
well we might've gone is
brown right before the fight.
You know a little pump me up.
That's three more belts ahead of cm
punk that she goes to the ground.
Yes.
That's a big difference.
So who knows what cm punk
has been able to do in the,
well,
he's been training for over a year.
Can you imagine if cm punk
goes in and she gets murked?
It'd be like from the
waterboy when Michigan,
the water boy water boy,
he certainly could write,
he could turn to get Merkt.
Who knows if this kid can strike,
like if he can strike,
if the kid has,
you could use it to any good strike.
Good luck.
Learn how striking a year she's got
doesn't have any striking under him.
Can you imagine?
Okay,
like you're going to harass signs,
strike some,
some dude who's got like some serious
knockout power and you're going to
practice for a year.
That's ridiculous.
I like cm punk as a person,
but for the sport I think
it's best if he gets murked
was that fucked all the way
going to make headlines.
I'm happy when anybody
says gets marked me too.
But gets high a style
like when you get stuck,
I forget
about rumble and Jon Jones go,
you never know man.
Rumble could starch him
and we said starts at like,
oh he could.
He could a good start to anybody.
Anybody in the world rumble can hit you
on the temple and your shit could just
go born you on your way.
I think John mops the floor.
He has the biggest head and
long steep I've ever seen.
I rob could almost head is gigantic.
It's a big fucking head.
If he connects against Jon Jones,
that's,
I don't think you will though.
I think John takes him down.
Where's the mountain?
Takes us heart.
People forget the Steepbank
got stopped by skyscraper.
Stephan's truth come out.
Yeah.
Stepdad knocked knockdowns truth,
man.
He's had some real tough fights.
There's a guy who has had
some real tough fights.
He's had some like brutal knockout losses
to the losses and put seven foot tall
basketball back in the day.
The kid had some mad potential and
still does because I was 26 27 right?
Yes.
So many fights on man.
His Age is not what I count.
I count.
He has what?
40 fights?
Some shit.
He's had some ruthless
knockouts inside the octagon.
And when's the last time you
saw seven foot tall grandpa?
Anyone?
They don't live long.
Anybody,
anybody?
No,
they don't know.
Yeah,
they all,
they're all have heart conditions.
They're just too big one.
If they can mitigate that today,
man,
when,
if they understand like
what it is that though,
like you're dying,
so fuck yourself bro.
Betty and I
both are going to be a hundred.
I'll be,
I'm on the back nine for sure.
Well,
you know what though?
Honestly do you really to live
past 80 fucking what kind of dog?
Shit.
Arthritis.
Written existence is that.
Oh,
by former athletes,
former athlete pass 80
good lord and less than
40 years from now.
Who the fuck knows?
Who knows?
Three
Daddy.
What's going to happen
when I'm 45 and he's yeah,
asked me that for Ron.
I said,
Shit,
you'll be a copy of all.
They're going to be dead.
That's what I said.
I just don't want to be dead when he's
going to be 45 [inaudible] 23rd sorry.
I know that you got to call us.
Oh,
April 23rd I'm Jim.
John Jones has been lifting weights.
Hey,
I love it.
All John's lifting weights.
Everyone was like,
no,
he's,
he's a good guy now.
Everything's all good.
Like cause he's post pictures,
lifting weights.
He's a fucking monster now.
John John's is ridiculous.
Good luck beating him.
Yeah.
And I don't think rumbles
going to wait for a,
for a title shot.
Yeah.
Now I said he's not going to like it.
I wouldn't wait to eat
if I was wrong by wood,
some quick work in.
And if he got busted with coke,
again,
blind beggar.
I love the guy.
We said,
oh shit,
that ain't snowflake.
I'm a fucker.
Came riding shot a low single,
just stayed on it.
Also hanging on to a Kamora
big guy.
So Hutto Johnson versus,
that's the cool manner.
Is that the Olympic wrestler to
gold medalists?
Yeah,
he bites it.
Those guys are super smart.
I was like,
Ooh,
girl is division guys are quick.
That's what I say.
This guy's a scramble.
What were we're talking about?
Are we just talking about
a rumble and that quick work?
Ryan Bader.
Oh,
I keep trying to finish that.
Uh,
Kimora like that's a hard move to
pull off on a strong dude as it is.
Right?
A guy strong is rumble was on top and
you don't even have half panic I think.
But he had no control when
he was holding on to it.
He had to do something with his legs.
He just didn't have the
dexterity to get into a position,
like a half guard or something and then
get up to the like to the dog fight,
right.
Rumble said,
what the fuck is thinking
at empty half at one point,
right?
Well the problem is
he's so fucking strong,
explosive.
The beginning of the round,
he's 100% he's not even remotely tired.
I jumped on your back or he's got you
on your back and it's not top of you and
you know one of those punches
is going to change your life.
One Punch.
Just one.
You gotta be really good on your back.
That's all that is.
You gotta be really fun
when you take him to grant.
John Jones is going to ram right there.
He tried to take an ankle.
No,
I'm saying to John Jones,
gonna take rumble down.
Maybe.
I promise he's going to incite
trip.
I'm take them down my,
he's going to break them
and the TKL they might not.
Man,
you're so confident.
How could you say that?
You're so calm.
Fucking,
I was just going to happen.
Dan was getting better and better
and now they're just trying to,
when Neil Ballantyne,
he's getting his grappling in order.
I hear you Joe.
It's all,
yeah,
I agree.
He's a monster.
Advertised.
Johnson was Johnson at Juco champion.
He asked.
He might,
he might,
he has the skills to starch.
Anyone in the words of Joe Rogan.
But yeah,
he's got the skills to
stiffen them all up.
It's mother whether or not he can apply
it against the very best of the best,
but he's at this edge like I
don't think he's done improving.
So he's had this edge right now.
We're only a guy like core me.
Aa Can beat him cause everybody else,
Jimmy Manawan,
everybody gets the fuck beat out of him.
Gustafson gets the fuck beat.
David.
I think it's five and five.
We'll take a flight has been a rumble.
Johnson's good fight match up.
Got this and got headbutted.
Actually they had one fight and he starts,
he smashed him.
Yeah,
I know.
I'm saying that doesn't happen every time.
I don't know when they don't know what
happens every time you got a good point,
no one goes,
it might not happen every time,
but with the data that we
have currently available,
[inaudible] scary guy who
knocks everybody dead.
He knocked him dead.
And so you've got to think,
okay,
first of all,
the kind of beating that
Gustafson took in that fight.
You don't want to take it again.
I agree that that was a bad beat about
the data when going to see Anthony
Johnson Bracey break.
He broke him.
He definitely broke guy break John Jones,
who's broken?
Everybody including DC DC.
That's not good.
Let's look at the data we have
here according to the data.
Right,
but that we're not talking about him.
We were talking about Gustafson.
I know you're talking about,
I'm saying,
but you got Jamie pull up that got,
but that was a monster fucking fight.
But definitely looks like watch
this and everybody can get broken.
Everybody.
If a guy says,
break you,
really multiple guy,
great ones don't get
broke because they're not,
they don't fight anybody that much
better than them at Lombardi said.
Vince Lombardi said,
fatigue makes cowards of us all.
And that's a great shirt.
Look,
I'll look up fatigue.
John was against mess of men,
right?
Yeah.
I've thought of that all the time.
Yeah,
it makes me a pussy.
Ah,
retired.
I turned to such.
Everyone does cardio shaves motherfucker,
but you know what man,
I've been getting into this straight
cardio over the last few months.
I've been doing like these hardcore
cardio workouts just because I hate them.
What are you talking about?
Like what kind of ridiculous sprints?
Like not like a Tabata protocol,
but I do a 32nd on 32nd off
on an elliptical machine.
I I adjusted from 16 which is pretty hard.
Pretty stiff to 20 which is like you're
wrestling this fucking thing and I'll do
these death sprints.
30 and 30 that's good.
Does it for how many 30 offhand?
It depends on,
it depends on what I'm trying to do,
but I do,
I do a 45 minute workout and what
I'm doing the 45 minute workout,
the first 15 minutes,
I'm just getting everything ramped up.
So the first 15 minutes was no sprints.
The first 15 minutes just keep it on
16 and going out at a very fast pace.
Then once I get to the first
15 minutes and I'm sweating,
then it's death runs.
I go on these 30 segment death runs it
for a whole 30 minutes depending upon how
much,
how long I can last,
how many death runs I can do.
Cause sometimes I can't do the death runs.
I just have to just pace myself at 16
but then when I feel like I've got my
heart rate down,
cause my,
my elliptical things got
a little heart rate thing.
Kind of just want to go.
Do you have that heart rate monitor?
Beast of a workout?
You just got to,
oh they're all,
they all can.
Everybody uses elliptical machines.
They just kind of go steady.
But if you go on a death run,
you got to go on a save your life,
save your loved one,
save your mom from fucking I do it.
I just do it.
No,
but I mean like what makes you a spread?
My inner insecurity.
Like think you're sprinting,
but you're like during the
sprint time you're like,
you know,
man,
I'm fucking proud as fast as I can,
whatever.
There's a number of revolutions per minute
and I want to keep it above a certain
number.
I don't remember.
I don't remember what it
is at at one 80 or at um,
at 20 but at somewhere where you want
your heart rate to be somewhere around one
80 and the,
I forget what the revolutions are because
there are different on the one that I
use at the gym versus the
one that I use at home.
But you could have a number where
you could keep it at that number.
So it's at like one 47 I think.
So when you hit one 47 and you just got
to fucking keep it there for 30 seconds
and it's big,
deep Wim Hoff breaths the whole time
and just wrestle this
thing for 30 seconds.
Do you know it's a nightmare and relax.
Yeah.
You know,
it's a nightmare.
He's setting just a little something.
Set the treadmill at 15 incline and it
put it at four miles an hour and walk,
walk for for 15 minutes.
Try to try to stay small
pace towards their kill.
You did.
I have,
I have.
I talked about what the cardio I did
from Metamora sprinting in the pool.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Well,
Tim Ferriss runs death runs in recovery.
That's what it's all about.
Yeah.
Think about the pool thing though,
is the way I did it was there's a
giant clock and every time it hits 12,
you sprint across the pool.
So when you get to the end of the pool,
whatever's left in that minute,
you get to rest.
Right?
Yeah.
So when you're,
when you're doing that,
no one has to tell you bust ass,
you're busting ass to rest.
Yeah.
Cause you know,
after the first,
uh,
maybe six laps or easy,
soon as the clock hits 12,
you bust ass across the pool.
Your sprint,
you get past and it's like you got 35
seconds to rest and then you rest and you
do it back.
As soon as it hits the 12 boom
after like 12 dad in the pool.
And no matter how chaotic it doesn't
take long breathing is you got
it.
No matter how tired you are,
you got to keep your breathing on
point because to swim your shit.
So you got,
you're like dying.
But at the same time,
there's something in your
mind and you're on dude,
survival mode,
you're dying,
but you're breathing's gotta be perfectly,
you're going to swallow water,
you're going to swallow water and use.
That to me was super fucking
crucial in the grappling.
Yeah,
exactly.
Wrestling with no matter
what you're breathing,
no matter how chaotic your situation is,
it,
uh,
you practice breathing
and chaotic situations.
Cause if you,
if you a hiccup at all,
you swallow water.
This is a good fight.
Allows that Makowski and Joseph
Benavidez this is a very good fight.
I've been looking forward to this.
Benevidez get another title shot.
You think maybe he's down at muscle farm
and he's a training with bang again,
doing all his training with bang.
Uh,
I don't know what's going on
with those guys in Sacramento.
What's happening?
Like how many,
how often they're,
him and Lance Palmer had
been bouncing all over.
I don't mean to cut you off.
Joe Jimenez Palmer had been bouncing
all over though to Jackson's and went to
muscle farm and a must for me.
No,
it's t they got a hell
of a team down there.
Tj,
Lance Palmer.
Benevidez Neil magni batch will benefit.
Has got to do what he's gotta do.
I mean,
he doesn't have any
meat in many years left.
I think he's in his thirties as well.
And especially,
I think he's 34 but at one oh boy.
Wow.
What's he do if he loses 25 well,
we wouldn't be loses to McCroskey
tonight and Makowski beats this guy,
but maybe just took them down.
I agree.
Let's say he fights Dj for a third time.
He loses.
Hey man,
we can't do four.
I'm sorry.
I can't do it for,
we got to move on.
Well,
what does he do then?
It's a real question.
Opens a gym.
Did you see,
did you see Justin Scoggins today?
Yes.
Jesus Christ Jesus.
He looked fantastic and fucking Scoggins.
Holy Shit.
God Damn Dude.
Yes.
That karate style shit about him,
dude.
I'm,
I'm not like you guys.
I'm not like an encyclopedia right now.
There's too many UFC.
He's like,
I can barely keep up.
I didn't know what the fuck he was,
but I saw him for the first time today,
the prelim and I,
I was thinking,
Holy Shit,
I guess Ray Borg,
because before,
before the fight started,
they had mentioned they got Scroggins
thinks he has the best movement in MMA.
And I'm like,
oh my motherfucking God,
how retarded can this guy be the best
fucking retard.
And then after one round I'm like,
okay,
he might have here,
can you,
can you keep the pace?
And then he was,
he looked really good on the
corner is grounded cause he rests,
his wrestling was very
good and it's striking.
Was this like coming from also,
he left and he's fighting right at it.
He's thrown every kick and
spinning everything like Holy Shit.
He's one of the best guys at standing
in that sideways karate style stance and
using their front leg too.
He Front Lake side kicks your
Thigh Front Lake sidekicks.
I Dunno if brainless
does that mother fucker.
I'm correct.
Or,
but he was talking about how,
and I don't know,
like I said,
I don't know anything about Scroggins,
but Brian,
Stan was saying that when
he fights a southpaw,
he fights more karate.
And when he fights ride that,
you know,
Orthodox,
he's fighting more and more.
We tire or something like that.
Like we fighting right hand the style
and it's finally left hand this style.
I'm like,
Holy Shit,
how cool is that
style?
But he changes it up.
Like right here.
I feel good when we tie right here.
I'm a karate guy.
You know why be fucked?
It's amazing.
His,
his sideways stance allows
them to use that front leg.
So if you're finding a guy that
doesn't know like that style,
you can get away with a lot of shit.
Like if you're used to a guy
who's fighting Moy Thai style,
would that light front
leg and the more of a,
like a closed off stance,
you can get away with
that with a Moy Thai guy,
but with a karate guy,
he'll stand sideways.
Like what standards.
Dot.
Yeah.
He'll stay on sideways and throw
those fucking front leg sidekicks.
And you don't know what to do.
Like he throws him from way outside.
He's like a lot of these
Moyie Thai style guys.
They're standing right in
front of each other for Zach.
What's north?
South?
He's all over the place.
It's still trained.
Anybody describe a fighter like that?
Have you ever heard of that before?
No.
Goggins probably told him that,
you know,
he probably had a conversation with
them about the different then before.
Have you heard?
I've never heard that before,
but it makes sense if
you see how good he is.
Birthday switch.
They're playing the same shit.
When the mayor,
there's like,
Holy Shit.
Well you know who else is
like super versatile and uh,
being able to uh,
switch back and forth.
Connor's a wizard with some good
uh,
former Strikeforce champion.
Just fought welterweight.
Uh,
dammit.
Saturday.
Yes.
Terex affidavit.
It's fucking hair happening as a
wizard and going back karate style.
He had Dutch kickboxer.
What does he,
um,
no,
not Dutch.
He is from Germany.
He's a German kickbox no,
Turkish targeting is Turkish.
No,
I want to say Belgium from Belgium.
That's Chris from Brussels.
He's from where,
uh,
vandamme his muscles from.
Well,
there you go.
There you go.
I love me man.
He's the reason I thought,
man,
I want to meet him a couple of times.
Damn movie.
I've seen him a couple times
in and he's got tight jeans on.
Always have beautiful bug kind of
Fan Paul ass and a fanny pack bubble.
But with a fanny pack.
He still has one.
I just do rocks when he
lives in Marina del Rey.
I live in Marina del Rey.
I see him all the time driving.
I don't want a super,
he meet.
We should have them on.
Ah.
Oh my God.
He's a great guy.
Condo near here.
Marina Marina del Rey blood van Damme on
this show would be fucking amazing when
I come or terrible decide
to make my comeback against
the Thai world champion.
He's been talking about making
a comeback for like tea.
Actually fight.
No,
listen to me.
If you want to see something that
is amazing that no one talks about,
you need to watch the John
Claude van Damme reality show.
I watch it fucking one CD.
You're talking about j B c,
d.
Great.
No,
no,
no.
It's a reality show.
A reality show is insane.
I love
watching with me.
I might come here,
Youtube.
I'm like,
watch how crazy people to be the best.
Well,
I think it aired in another
country and Baird it.
Showtime picked it up.
What is real ridiculous?
He's amazing.
He keeps talking about having this fight,
but he's been scheduling for years.
Thai guy.
No,
he's his tiger.
It gives them a little scratch.
My friend come on hugging,
fighting
my face.
He pretends he's going to fight this
guy and they fucking knuckle up.
They have these,
these press conferences and he goes,
he's batshit crazy.
Does this speech about having
to fight for the children.
I'm tow of the cocaine.
I'm done with this.
I'm done with the party.
That motherfucker needs better friends,
better friends.
He gets up,
he gets GAC to the gills on coke and he
goes to the price was brushing all the
guards.
They fly him out to Chechnya,
October.
Those two fucking disco with a
with a fucking champagne bottle.
With both hands and he wakes up
in the morning and it feels bad.
It feels bad that the children,
the children,
I'm going to fight to show
that you got to watch it,
have it.
You got to watch it to be on the show.
He's bat shit crazy now.
You will have it.
He still loves me.
Does he fly private everywhere?
He's a bad motherfucker.
Got money and everybody
made all these money.
Listen,
movie was great.
He made a lot of money,
but that last week we
probably made eight ball,
$8 $70 for all those other movies
that he made his whole life.
If he was just reasonably frugal,
he has hundreds of millions of dollars.
Really?
Oh my God.
How much money did he make
over his career cop baby?
That was,
it
was a blockbuster.
I went to go see her on that Friday
night and we had to get [inaudible].
Here's something you have.
He's Elvis and Easter certainly have
to consider ownership of the movies,
sales of the movies.
He existed back in the day
where people bought DVDs.
Oh Shit.
This is a good fight.
Makowski on top.
He existed back in the day of blockbuster.
Back in the day where
people would buy movies.
You get a percentage of that.
You get a percentage of it
when they sell it to showtime,
Hbo,
Cinemax,
Tvs,
all that shit.
He got to pretend you have all of that.
I use ball to you.
He was producing,
he was a part of the
ownership of those films.
He might have made an
ungodly amount of money.
Yeah.
Brian,
could you beat up how much they man,
how much he,
man,
I don't think anybody can beat up tableau.
Hold on.
Jamie.
Jamie
up seeing a lot of information online,
but something I just found said he is the
hot top 10 highest paid actors for 2016
with an estimated 82 million in combined
or no.
Oh,
well let's look at his overall earnings.
This
dude,
I am so hungry.
Sales two 45 $245 million,
like 45 million people don't understand,
but he still looks good.
Let's on flying private.
I was like,
oh,
he's being stupid with his money.
Fine.
No,
he's fine,
dude.
He Scrooge McDuck.
He owns a football team
and vodka and per few does.
Yes.
A lot of money.
[inaudible] John Claude van Damme,
you need to stay in Lake [inaudible] name.
I love that guy.
He's my hero.
He's got so much money.
He could paint a,
got a fight where they can choreograph.
He's paying them to show up
a fight,
but they choreograph press conferences.
He would fuck up everyone in this room.
Maybe he's thought about actually
fighting about three or four times,
but most of the time what it is is just
getting together and saying that you're
thinking about fighting
and to schedule a it,
but I have movies tend to,
he blinded somebody in one of his movies
with that wheel kick and he had to do a
deposition at his,
at a trial about how,
look at him.
Look at him.
He's a brilliant,
hey,
who's better looking at Denver,
Joe Real.
Oh,
he's definitely not as
good looking as Alan.
Now back in the day time in the day,
it was really close
to him all day.
There's no one better looking than
Allen Joe ban that just different.
You don't get better looking.
That's a good cost is not going to be,
this is back.
Oh Shit.
Look at this.
Meanwhile we don't have
any idea who won and
if any of you fuckers try
to say Benevidez get robbed.
I was
watching it,
I think is head comes out.
We would do a worse job than you know.
Name your least favorite judge.
I got benefit as the head
cause he's been fucked.
Turned to the screen.
Get tired.
I can feel it.
I could feel it.
Do you put the jeans on man,
right?
No sweats off.
Put those genes out right now.
Brian cal and a pair of the barbell jeans.
So props to barbell jeans.
Eddie Bravo,
which just took the
second large glass of Vino
low.
If you were in a fine restaurant,
it's a double son.
Come on most.
Of course
he pours a slight sipping thing.
It's a,
this is a delicious
wine by the way.
Let me tell you something about Cowan.
This mother fucker knows his one.
I've got a dinner with him and he gets
in a conversation with this shit more.
Yay.
The bed says,
what do you have in a burgundy from 97 d?
And the guy goes,
oh shit,
this mother fucker's for real cow.
Start talking about different comp,
different grapes that are
grown on different hillsides,
and he'll explain,
he'll explain some shit.
We were at this restaurant
and the small we AA was like,
yes,
correct.
That's correct.
Correct.
Who started,
he started talking about,
oh my God,
I got to work on your technique.
Inside Kik is you gotta pick your knee up.
I think John Claude van Damme.
Where's those two though?
For sure.
Stretch.
That's why you have to
put your knee up higher.
They look good and there's nothing
that has nothing to do with stretching.
It's just you just haven't
thrown a sidekick in a while.
It's a little rusty.
You can do it.
You gotta put your socks on before
he came back and people ask him,
why do you want to put your socks on?
Does that help your kicking?
You want to put a shoe on?
Oh,
you like to kick with shoes on?
Do you still wear those shiny shoes so
that you could throw a roundhouse kicks
quicker cause he pivots.
If you have a shiny sol
like that's terrible.
You got to pick your knee up.
You have no,
see it's not bad,
but you have a inherent flaw in your
technique that probably was never,
never explained to you for 49 million.
Ain't bad.
It's pretty good.
Not Right.
I wouldn't want to get hit by that.
Get hit hidden.
Riding your shower.
That's where you would get hit.
Oh Shit.
I washed my hands still spinning kicks.
Right
dude,
it's wrong though.
Sounds those genes or Helen.
I used to being serious there.
Are you being serious?
Show me what?
Show me a real front lake side for real.
All Bullshit.
Well,
just this from here and just throw it.
Let me see the spinning one.
Show him spinning.
One kick.
Yeah,
that's my favorite that he does.
It's my favorite two old tear you.
You just all you have to do different.
The all you're doing wrong.
You're coming up.
You're foot is going up from the
ground like an almost like a half moon,
right?
Yeah.
You want to get your knee up higher.
That's one of the cool
things about those jeans.
Way Higher than that.
You cool things about those June.
Yeah.
There's genes.
These genes that were wearing,
they're like sweat pants,
man.
You she just had no,
no,
no.
Don't throw the kick
until your knee is up.
Get your knee up first
and then throw the kick.
The problem is you're doing
both at the same time.
No,
no,
no.
Don't throw the kick
into your knees up hot.
Lift your knee up way high past
your waist and then throw the kick.
Yes,
me up first and then don't
look over your stomach.
Look over your shoulder.
Yeah,
but knee first here.
Hold on.
This fucking hysterical.
This is ridiculous.
That's why I'm drunk.
I can't watch.
Watch Joe is going to go off.
Dude.
Genes on genes,
on genes here,
up here,
up.
So flexible pipe companion from here.
Turn your shoulder to the right turn.
You shown to the right to right now.
Extent extension and extension straight.
Don't look over your stomach.
Look over your shoulder like this.
Like that.
That's how you look.
I know that's not yet.
That's the flexible.
You're fine left right from here.
Watch.
Oh sons.
Damn
fucking blush.
You lift your knee and then kick.
I still think John Claude van Damme
beats the fuck out of both of you.
Then kick watch one too.
Okay.
Ready?
I'm not mad at Joe's format.
All know no one and then two one up.
All right,
and he can do play by play.
Shit.
Don't look on your stomach.
I don't know what the fuck.
Well,
I know John Claude van
Damme would be proud.
Are you calling your shoulder?
Look,
I'm throwing it up here.
I'm like this.
I'm never like this.
Look at Joe's ass.
When he throws the kick,
it's just looking at it.
Don't look,
don't look at the foot.
He has a set of [inaudible].
Look at the foot honeydews on them,
right into the glutes.
Looking deeply into them.
Dude,
I'd love to see our
actual taekwondo match.
Shrink,
Callen and relevant.
I would just stare at their asses
to my barbell fucking monster.
They're awesome.
Right?
Yeah,
we,
you see my cakes,
you see mine?
Just fundamentally a
little off a little bit.
He's been here.
So you get there,
but that dose does,
that span.
Here is,
everybody fucks that up.
Everybody fucks that up.
It's a number one thing about the side
kick that people get wrong and it changes
everything.
If you learn to do it right,
you learned to get that knee up high.
The power differences fucking substantial.
No,
no.
You just gotta do it
right with Rogan's help.
You could be the best
kick yourself.
Dear diary today.
Here's a two bro.
Here's the thing.
You don't just throw it,
you have to throw it right
or don't throw it right.
You can't be happy with the scoop
and the scoop doesn't exist.
Right?
You can't do it.
Fuck your shit.
Kick like that.
I'd be sick for a year.
Just run
through a bad time.
But it's not,
it's not a bad sidekick.
It's just you need to
learn how to do it right.
You need a knee has to come up
high and then you can do it right.
Like once,
once I showed you how to do it,
you were doing it way better.
I'll tell you right.
Last one was the best one.
I'll tell you right now.
You feel that sidekick with
John Claude van Damme in here.
He's gonna throw up.
He's never coming back.
No Dude,
can we get better?
I'm Dallas to Kim's dangerous.
It's real simple.
You either do it right or you don't do
it and that's the only way to be a good
test is 5:00 AM all ready for my,
my,
my last cell.
You will get quicker.
You'll feel it.
I'll put a pad you up like Justin.
I put Justin my Laos and pads.
Well I pay him.
Well that's why I hit him on heavy bags
cause you'd be like Freddie Roach about
three years.
Leg Pads on him.
I have leg one guy body pat on him.
I don't kick them in the body though.
I only kicked him in the tie pads but I
fucked him up with body shots like body
shots,
flexeril.
It's so fun.
It gets to the point where here like
paying like dudes to not wear pads.
Let me fuck you up.
Don't
think someone's done that and
you're just bringing them in.
You just come in and you take a beating
and it'll give you fucking thousand
dollars time for the kid and he can't.
You know too much about brain damage.
Who knows what's going on with your
[inaudible] going on with your liver.
When you get fucking like they'll sign
Joe's kick cowboy and the body in that
need of the body.
Hi.
Did you show him those spinning heel
kicks and so his body to listen,
man.
People get launched across the fucking
the floor from attorney side kick to the
body.
They get launched
back kicks.
How many,
well,
there's a video of me on youtube
kicking the guard and he soars.
Yeah,
he sources the video of me doing that
and they took it down because it's too
dense.
Too dangerous.
Makes Sense.
I slew him.
I said,
yeah,
I told you guys,
I called it a love that guy.
Oh Shit.
He was right.
I was playing a lot of
games week in this corner.
A kick to the body is always
painful because your leg is strong.
Even if you have a half ass kick,
he throws a kick to the body.
It's usually stronger than most people's
punches unless you're like some tune
off type care.
So your shoulders should
take to kick around.
But when you learn how
to kick and you kick,
good kick to the body is horrific.
It's horrific.
I save your shoulders account.
You should work on your body.
Stop,
dedicate your life.
All I'm doing,
I cannot do the pocket.
Dedicate your life to kicking.
I think you can afford to pay.
Have to fucking,
hey,
it's not going to kill him.
Kill him,
kill him.
Dude's will only be able to last
like 90 seconds tops with Joe.
Joe's going to,
he kicks hard,
dude,
he's going to need eight guys at
49 he kicks his heart as anybody
have a few months.
That's $10,000 you do the kick harder.
I've been around kicking for a long time.
You kick harder the name.
Well,
I learned it.
I just said I've been
around kicking Toronto.
Good.
That'll feel dated.
Do that.
If he kicks hard back in the day and I,
and I was right next to him.
Who I watched boss Rutan.
Hi.
Come on.
Oh my gosh.
How did it sound like I sound
like somebody shooting a shotgun.
Sean's I've ever heard kick a bag,
Pedro.
Yup.
Pedro has those leg kicks.
They scared me more than anything I've
ever seen in my life to wide his hips
I've ever seen.
When I saw him kick the bag
of Beverly Hills Jujitsu.
Oh,
all I thought of is,
is just would take one and I'd be over.
There's no way I would survive
if he kicked me once in the leg.
My Shit would just give up.
Had the hardest cake I've ever seen.
Who?
Shane Carlin was a gorilla.
He,
but he never threw every easily
is too tempted to throw him.
He wasn't tempt to throw them in the fight
because they thought to heavy weights
get counter.
He fucked up so many guys legs in the gym.
They banned them from kicking.
Oh,
how am I gonna stop kicking?
Well,
that's terrible idea.
Why didn't they fucking pay people?
The money does go down.
Just
like car would like,
didn't Trevor Whitman train him?
Why didn't Trevor have him throwing kicks?
Because Trevor's a wicked
kicks kicks all the time,
but then you want to be stowed
in sparring and do it in fights.
Man,
that's too bad.
It's like to a show heavy,
like fuck up your ACRM win
a fucking freak specimen.
As far as like his skeletal muscular
structure every day for how many years?
I can't even imagine.
How would you,
I don't know how you get
out of the car today.
I'm going to sh chat stuck in Denver.
Not much to do.
Do they got to start wrapping
or play basketball or class?
Spark car.
Would you wear a football
helmet or something?
I would never Helma wouldn't help.
Bigger thing for him to hit.
Oh Dude.
I was living in boulder and I was
training in a mall Easton's and this guy
walked in and I was,
we were in the middle of the class,
right?
We're going over drills
and I saw this guy walk in.
I'm like,
that's not even a real person.
Can be a real person.
Then I realized it was car when he had
his tee shirt on that looked like it
probably was made for me.
Dude,
his fucking arms were
my thighs essentially.
He looks like juggernaut from x men.
He was at the time,
I mean he wasn't making,
he had to make to 65 so it
car when he's cutting weight.
Yeah.
He's caught in a little bit of weight.
He was so big.
You'll quick me.
She takes the hottest MMA,
so I a one two biddies on it.
The booty is just out of control and all.
She's just a nice person.
She's sweet by far.
The hottest girl.
I think she's also just,
yeah,
she's awesome.
There's some fucking pretty decently hot,
hotter.
Some girl that just started fighting
and Bella toward it looks really hot.
Really?
Yeah.
It was pictures of her tiff time.
Balmain.
I would've kicked her out of bed frame
and crackers and kicking me in the face.
Roses,
roses,
hottest shit.
Paige vanzants hot.
Yeah,
I know he pays.
Got Her ass whooped like that.
I'm like,
I'm off that train now.
No page.
I'm a page fan.
Don't get me twisted.
I'm a page fit,
but still Misha Tate pound
for Michelle Waterman is sick.
She has married,
what the fuck
know?
Agent's Voice of morality.
Oh really?
That's all I don't
like seeing him around.
They get punchline that,
well,
enjoy this kick then.
So
Shit,
they try everything in their
power not to show that.
No,
they don't.
They show that fucker all the time.
That's in the loop.
Now.
You know the loop,
that knockout loop to
plays to Baba O'reilly,
the WHO Song,
they put Ryan on the,
Oh shit.
Of course he does.
He,
he's a part of it.
You fucked up.
You fucked up light.
Dana's going to listen to this and
that shit's going to be marked out.
They listen.
Holly Holm is a fucking legit champion.
He doesn't play favorites that much.
He might have a love for
Rhonda like as a person,
but the bottom line is business.
Business is business,
and Holly is the fucking champions.
And with a spectacular result,
you couldn't remove that spectacular
because that was the most spectacular
result in the history of
women's MMA in the UFC,
right?
100% yes.
I saw Holly on a private jet,
which is what we're seeing now.
Holly's having her
first FiveStars trouble,
so it was this mother fucker say before
the podcast started [inaudible] he got,
we're talking about this for me.
I sucked you in.
Fuck you bro.
I can't handle this on my local
kitchen.
About to go into Ketosis,
emotion,
emotional cutoff,
I think.
I think it's really easy.
Meet Misha and Holly.
I think if if Nisha keys,
it took Holly down.
If Meesha can't take Holly down,
Holly's going to win.
She's easily going to precision or she
can be shamed if she could take her down.
If she could take her down.
I don't think,
I don't think Holly's Jujitsu
is anywhere near me shows
and she's going to write her up.
Hey,
Misha went three rounds.
Hit the brakes.
Let's not say she's going to do
this because we really don't know.
I really have a problem
when people get that
he's going to lie to her.
Hey,
get her mind her up.
I don't really think we should say that.
You don't think that's a fair assessment?
Just disrespectful.
Disagree.
This is what I think.
I think honestly,
I think Misha Tate is a better grappler.
I think we should take dominated Sarah
McMahon on the ground and flipped her
over on her back and held her down,
which is a giant accomplishment.
Yes.
How grappled her out ground around and
showed some bad ass striking against
Jessica [inaudible] with a Ken strife.
I man also is not going to be ridiculous.
She's not going to charge.
She's not going to be Chin
up face first Thompson out.
All I'm saying is that I don't
think it's disrespectful.
I would never be disrespectful.
However,
no,
no.
10 minutes ago.
Hey Dash rectal junk lot for sure.
No,
the chitlins genes haven't
been worked out yet,
but those jeans are
like fucking yoga pants.
They need to be these fibers.
The fibers is still tight.
I put these on today and
I from the broken man,
look
at how flexible you
are from the same pack.
I'm getting turned on.
I like listen,
listen.
They come from the same box.
These are new.
Those are,
hold on,
let me,
yeah,
now the,
now they're broken.
I said no because I still
have the tag on them.
I don't know about that
does look very broken down.
I think you're lying.
I just got them now.
You put them on that machine you bought,
you bought it,
put them on a gene machine.
Just listens.
I didn't buy them.
They send them to me for free.
I don't think it's
the greatest strikers ever,
ever for women in MMA.
MMA you wanna you want
to Emj check I signed,
I would say Holly,
Holly and Holly.
Holly and you want to say that to say
she would like anybody out for k o power
but to say that Hollywood line up,
anybody's not disrespectful.
It's a compliment to Holly.
It's not a dis this till we were
saying she's going to light her up.
I believe that.
And that's not being disrespectful or
Meesha might take her to the ground to be
able to dominate her from there cause
I've taking her down her take down the
fences.
Awesome.
She's never been to,
she might not be able to get taken down.
She's never been down before.
She can,
if she,
if we should think DFA,
I think Misha is going to,
uh,
if she can take her down,
she's going to be all over on the ground.
We don't know cause it's really a mystery.
Like we haven't seen Holly on the ground
except for those brief moments with
Rhonda.
What she got out of Ron is armbar
attempt and where she took Rhonda down.
All we know,
it's all I know as far as you might have
some inside information from gyms for
people who trained with her.
I'd always seen,
I know this,
I think it's a tougher matchup
stylistic wise for Holly then Rhonda.
Well,
what do you know?
um,
I know that uh,
she's not obsessed with Jujitsu.
She's one of those and there's
a lot of MMA fighters like that.
I couldn't go,
I could just rattle
names off left and right.
There's a lot of guys,
they just want to stand and bang and work.
The wrestling.
I'll work to get up.
They don't want to
fucking learn Jiu Jitsu.
There's so many.
They're still around.
They didn't want to work on their back.
They just want to beat
the shit out of people,
take them fucking down and get on top or
not even fucking take them down to stay
in bang and,
and work on their takedown defense.
If they get taken down,
work on getting back up.
That's sad.
That tree.
That's barbarian.
That's Holly.
Yeah.
That's a lot of guys like that.
And I hear Holly is one of those guys.
She just wants to stay in the girl girls.
She's one of those fighters.
And what,
what those,
uh,
fighters all have in common that they're
generally not known to have a dangerous
weapons off their back and they usually,
she gives a fuck up and kitchen
kicks bitches in the face,
especially in women's divisions
do,
does she have to worry about,
and the women's division,
she works on takedown defense a lot
and she works on getting back up a lot.
That's what I hear.
And that then kicking,
you can get it through their
lesson to be learned that MMA math
doesn't really work and
it styles really match up.
Weird sometimes.
And this might be a case like
the Misha Tate [inaudible],
Holly Holm fight,
I think a very tough fight.
She's sneaky,
she's sneaky and she's tired.
She does a lot of good.
She's got a lot of good skills.
He's got good skills.
She's handwriting or two fights
with their fucking hands up high.
She doesn't rush in and take
crazy chances and she can pop.
She dropped Jessica.
I was super game as fuck.
She ain't she,
she's crying and she's
great in the transition.
Really good trend and like,
like Holly,
she's lost and been beaten up before
she got beat up by cats and gone,
oh she's been to the mountain.
Just came back strong hundred
percent that coming back stronger.
It's big cause she came
back and beat Jessica,
I and Sarah McMahon.
I thought like showing more
determination show like more grit.
Like she was her back was against the
wall after losing that fight to cat and
she came back stronger.
Let's see what I've seen from
what I've seen with my eye,
whether I'm right or not,
it just looks like Holly.
Holly not only is a higher level striker,
I think Holly,
just from what I've seen,
has much more snap and speed.
No question.
But you know,
it just so many fast.
She's a 19 he shows,
he shows record is way better than,
but Maven,
here's the thing.
Yeah.
But then mainly a striker
and not an MMA person.
Right.
He sang her boxing is
unquestionably better.
Unquestionably.
She's arguably going kicked best striking
credentials ever in the history of the
women's division.
Sure.
And kicking time,
world boxing champion.
The only one who comes
close as you want her,
cause she's six time world more touch him.
Right.
When it comes to actual champions.
But Meesha can grapple,
she can clinch,
she can avoid striking and she doesn't
necessarily have to kickbox with her.
So it becomes a very
different proposition.
So if they went kickboxing,
kickboxing,
yes.
If they had an MMA kickboxing match,
which is where they essentially,
the Rhonda fight was except for two
brief moments if they went kickboxing.
Yeah.
Holly's gonna fuck her up,
but in MMA me Shit's fucking smart.
She's,
she's sneaky.
She knows a lot of shit and she's been
there before and she's tough and she
knows she's tough.
She knows she can grind it
out in a grueling brawl.
Yes.
And she has a real shot.
She's got a real shot.
See,
I think,
I think Misha,
she's never going to beat Rhonda,
but Meesha can be Holly to be champion.
I just think stylistic wise,
it's a much better match.
The Holly Holly's lateral movement,
we won't know a lot,
but I know in mixed martial arts,
I think stylistic was Misha has a way
better chance beating Holly and then she
does Ron.
Yeah.
Also there's a big difference between
someone who is fighting off the back leg
as a counter person,
which Holly is just ridiculously
good at her counters.
Her timing was fucking spectacular,
but Rhonda was presenting
a predictable target.
There was a lot of ride forward.
There was a lot of aggression.
It's,
I'll show,
you know Holly had to do so all
hog it had to do was be patient,
find the right foot work and catch her
coming in cause she knew she was coming
in.
So it was an exercise and
moving back in countering,
she knew exactly what
she was preparing for me.
She's not going to do that.
He'll remember.
But if you remember like
there was a a fighters like
most notably Patrick Otay that fought
Anderson Silva and he didn't lead and when
he didn't lead,
Anderson did not look nearly as good.
Horrible.
He's a horrible fight because
cat [inaudible] has an iron jaw,
he's got knockout power and he's smart.
So what does he do?
He knows that Anderson is
a wizard at countering,
so he's not his predictable,
usual aggressive.
So I don't think those two
girls on the same level is no,
they're not on the same level.
Holly is Holly's on a very
high level Shaman for women.
When I was at a higher level striking
did an under hook and trying to find out
what's the right,
this is what we're going to find.
What surprised me.
I think Holly,
I think Holly is so much stronger.
I was amazed at how she looked
and so much stronger than Rhonda,
Rhonda strongest Shit.
And it felt like Hollywood does fight.
Ain't got his phone around by the way.
And she's gonna be stronger than me
despite out of the first early phase.
Xiao Casey's house looked like Doodoo.
They Lee.
Well,
he's had some rough fights,
man.
Patrick Cummings really
beat him down last round.
That was in Brazil.
That was a crazy fight,
man.
Oh,
sees a motherfucker.
He's in the first round and
he's a super athlete man.
And that powerful left kick sick.
He's got a nasty left kick.
He's a dude that just
keeps getting better too.
If you can get him down,
if he can get him down,
you can win the III trial
for the NFL a bunch of times.
Nope.
I thought he did.
Nope,
he just played that,
uh,
you know,
she had Tennessee and
then went straight to,
uh,
he didn't,
he's a serious athlete,
ma'am.
Maybe you went to combine or something,
but yeah,
not the NFL combine,
but he really,
no,
he didn't get tryouts with the NFL
when he knocked out shogun step away.
Left Hook.
He was nasty.
He let everybody know what's up.
I'll do.
It was a big message Jamie.
While they're doing shogun.
No shogun.
It is.
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
Who's Liotta fighting Leona's
fighters don't understand him.
Nothing.
That's a weird fucking for
nothing on both of those.
How dare you.
Thanks for nothing.
You wouldn't watch that.
Nah.
10 years ago I would.
Okay.
I will absolutely watch Leo's crunk
always crunk crunk photo oto fight.
Cause the Oto just uh,
a year and a half ago knocked out Mark
Munoz with that wicked left head kick.
Leo was one of my favorite
people on the planet.
I'm just saying and sold.
Can we give them something else?
Well,
Dan Henderson has a bunch of fights left
and his contract and I think he still
thinks that he can do it.
And uh,
you got to let it go like that.
He deserves the right.
Yeah.
Two unsuccessful attempts
to professional football.
So there it goes.
You were right.
Brian doesn't say NFL though,
does it?
Well,
I would imagine on football.
No,
not at [inaudible] Italian.
You can be CFL.
AFL,
really peripheral ton.
Brendan Schaub,
former NFL player with fucking logic.
Maybe you should listen.
I know
for 20 years
who got hurt?
He kicked him and he fucked his leg up.
He kicked him fucked up.
Where did he kick him?
I need to see him again so he
can't get his legs fucked up leg,
but he's limping.
He might hurt his knee.
His training camp.
His team.
I have no clue.
I have no idea who he's
trading in his leg.
His left leg is real wobbly man,
man.
She changed.
When you went to South Park,
did you see what happened at the April?
This is auctioned off.
Did you see what happened to me?
He kicked a homeboy and hurt his leg.
Kicking him.
Oh,
like Shinny Shin.
Something happened like this
back to ou stuck it again.
He's not moving.
I saw that was the wrong leg.
He's not moving at face.
Y'All just to the right leg.
You're talking about the left leg and
he switched us.
He started out in south Pandosy.
Switch cause is fucked up so he's
kicking with the fucked up leg is is
supporting line the leg.
His right leg is super fucked up.
Punched.
Oh that's weird.
Yeah,
he got his knee messed up.
Isn't it weird just to try to see
a guy tried to hide that shit.
You know what was the
best I've ever seen at it?
You're right.
Hall.
Uriah hall had his foot fucked up so
bad that it's toe was hanging off and he
came back to his corner and you can see
we've got a camera on it so we could get
a look at it.
His foot was completely
fucked up like his toe.
The bone was sticking out of his toe.
Jon Jones,
that was after the fight.
That was after it was over your Riaa.
What I'm saying is he
went back to his corner,
like barely could walk and then when
the round started that motherfucker
completely ignored it.
He was throwing kicks with it.
It's fucking toe was hanging off and
he's throwing wheel kicks with it.
Yeah.
There's this total like you
see how fucked up it is.
It was broken off to the right
and the bone was coming out.
Like I could see the worst air shows.
Uriah hall is a bad motherfucker.
He is a bad motherfucker.
He hasn't fun awhile,
Huh?
Well he lost a gay guard member.
Beat gay guard.
Then he lost two.
I'm sorry dude.
We lost her
being very,
very careful here.
Huh?
The fight we gay guard was
spectacular victory for him.
1:00 AM I getting gate guard
still ranked higher than them.
That's crazy.
That doesn't make any sense.
Fells ladies.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Tail slate.
This and I haven't seen,
and this is another one who fought
very smart against Anderson Silva.
He's another one that went five
rounds where they're swinging,
so I'm like,
oh,
you had him.
Wow.
You had him look at that look.
Oh Shit.
It looks like he can throw some
elbows from the guard and open.
Same.
Who's on top right now with a phage?
His guard.
He's got good left elbow with the card.
One thing about a guy like phaseout though
is it Fazio was a really good striker
and really good strikers are hard to
ground and pound cause they don't panic.
They don't lock up,
relax.
They get used to getting hit.
They know how to roll with things
and they know what's coming.
You know like their Iq as far as like
striking like where the right hand's
common,
where the left hand is coming,
what position you're in to put
like real torque behind something.
You rarely catch some clean like look out,
see how clever he's moving
when he's off his shit.
Fight Anderson back in the day on and off.
No he fought king mo and knocked him
out and strike force to win the title.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Yeah but you know phase
Xiao.
Is that a tough stint?
Yeah,
he's had some ups and downs.
He might've took,
he might've gotten the UFC like
a little later in his career.
You know,
it'd be a little late for
like him at his best effort.
Should they be massaging
has near right now.
Do something.
No,
I don't know what's wrong with it.
I mean,
it's Ashley,
could it have been a charley horse?
We know that Sasha is,
fuck,
I push.
It depended upon he's
putting a skin patch.
Might hurt his foot.
I feel like this a bad idea.
Put ice before you go out there.
Yeah.
Might be praying the inflammation down.
Oh,
he might've broke his foot
when he threw that leg kicks.
He's,
you know,
he might've blew his knee out or blue.
His foot out or something.
Yeah.
Damn man,
that's too bad.
Yeah.
He's having a hard time on it.
See how it's kind of wobbly.
Kind of get that win.
But it's just interesting.
You know,
like little variations in someone's gait.
You could see it.
Oh,
look at them.
This is why I think I'm so excited about
what's going on right now with MMA,
with guys working on this crazy footwork
like the Duane Ludwig like camp with
the Tj Dillashaw style foot work,
Dominick Cruz's footwork,
Conor Mcgregor's footwork,
emotion coach show all this coaches.
Yeah,
tape.
She texted me the day goes,
hey man,
you have any movement coach in La?
I text back.
Fuck you.
I don't deal with that bullshit.
Fuck fuck you started laughing.
Do that is so funny.
If you an MMA fan,
you understand why that will.
That is so funny because I'm
guilty of it as much as anybody,
but I can't shut the fuck up about
moving balls deep in it balls deep.
I had the move game guy.
Can we keep that guy who made coach?
He was great.
Oh,
what's your uh,
background?
Uh,
as a kid I climbed on
trees and played with rock.
Oh,
mark tick.
Oh yeah.
What's your degree?
I played with Legos as a kid.
Yeah.
It would've been nice if he
had to like a more like ready
as zero.
And I think he knows a lot.
I mean
real about it.
I think he knows a lot
about proprioception and
some of the things he was
talking about,
about balance and coordination.
Look like in Carlos fight.
Listen man,
he's always wanting to,
you won that fight anyways,
but I don't think he moved to,
well I think he's only been working with
them for a short amount of time and you
know as much as I do that new things
you're going to incorporate into like high
level cage fighting.
It takes a long time to really apply.
That's not climb on logs.
Maybe go to the gym and grapple.
I had a ponytail
I'll look like just someone on the
underground said that some stealing their
line.
They all looked like Jesus.
Why don't ponytails whoever
it is that did that.
A tweet me so I can,
there you go.
What's your background Dan?
He went,
Nah man.
I just like typed on rocks as a kid,
climbed some trees.
As soon as I heard
mom turn this shit
off,
why was,
I was confused still even
at the end like how the,
how they sort of design their protocol.
I mean what,
what,
how he designs like what they're going
to do that day out of my first son.
It was such bullshit,
Connors,
move on.
Do you want?
Okay.
For everyone else stayed the fucking
the gym and work on your sports.
This if you haven't done it.
I honestly belay man,
unless you've done it,
you wouldn't have like,
okay,
here's a perfect example.
You're doing yoga now.
Would you not fit?
That shit was for housewives
before you ever did it.
Nah Son.
I liked that shit.
Go to yoga to be like,
listen,
I'm going to beat Andre or last night.
Let me go get some hot.
Yo Listen,
I'm not talking about why you as an
experienced yoga person goes to yoga.
I'm talking about your
prejudice against Yoga.
Before you ever did yoga,
what was it?
I didn't happen.
I did.
I'm open minded bull shit.
I swear.
How dare you fucking green some aligned.
Show us or show us your roots.
You didn't
think
it
turned out to be way easier,
way harder.
Well,
you didn't think your
perception of it was there.
It was way easier than it actually was.
Hey baby is way harder.
Harder,
but in the middle of training camp,
I'm like,
thank God for Mrs. Downs in this yoga.
Otherwise I wouldn't move.
Is good,
but there's a lot of movement in training,
right?
I mean jabbing
your chuck full of movements that don't
they have a lot of yoga movements and
movements.
Yes.
Yeah.
There's definitely a lot of movement,
a lot of payrolls and you to see a degree
and he sees some sort of scientific,
hold on a second there because
there's people that don't get degrees.
Like how about,
how about the a a natural
that Hixon Gracie tributes
to a lot of its flexibility
and movement like before
these movement coaches.
Okay.
This is what people
that need to understand.
Back in the fucking early
nineties Hickson was like a guy.
You didn't want it.
He was like candy man.
Yeah.
He didn't want to say
his name three times.
It's true.
He did.
He was the motherfucker.
Motherfuckers is heartbeat down,
all that stuff.
He was a Yogi.
He's a legit Yogi and gymnastic natural.
Exactly.
It was both.
He come,
he applied,
he applied fire broth.
That's why he's alleging also
then he did 40 years of Jujitsu
it out from all the graces he stood out.
Hixon Gracie.
All of them would cause he did the movie.
This is backwards.
That's
a,
maybe it's the maybe had
something to do with that.
Yeah,
but here what you're saying here too.
Yes.
It's not,
they're not mutually exclusive.
Exclusive Hex and the reason why he was
the greatest ever it was because he was
the perfect storm.
He was the guy who was super smart.
He was super tough.
He was a war.
He had a warrior mentality and he was
intelligent enough to apply a bunch of
really unconventional training
modalities like some serious yoga,
that fucking video of him on
the bars and Santa Monica,
but before he fought
in Japan Valley Tudos,
he's doing balance beam shit.
Go into a full split standing there
on his fucking bar on the beach.
He's doing all these real,
this is,
I'm not saying the movement doesn't work.
It was both.
It was I.
Hell you say it doesn't help
that he's been doing anyway.
Positive Jim.
I'm saying it was an MMA fighter in the
UFC on my list of priorities to become a
UFC champion.
Hiring a movement coach who his background
is climbing on rocks and climbing
trees.
I'm going to fuck it.
I can't say it about
this foretell guy he had.
Now he's a god.
That diary don't diss
him cause I'll come out.
Fuck you ain't gotta give you say
only know side kick the fuck out.
Don't know what his total
or one the core can do.
But I know he has the respect of Carlos
condit so he's got my respect and I
enjoy talking to them and
I think he knows a lot.
So I disagree with you on that.
But I don't know if he can do
what that Edo Portel God can do.
But we're talking about
mindset moves like,
yeah,
I agree.
It seems like it's not real Joe.
All I'm saying is if you're going
to dedicate your time to something,
I don't know if that's the way to go.
Here's why.
I'm not sure you're right
guys like Richard Martinez,
we brought this up before you.
He a a fantastic breakdancer and
the ability to manipulate his body,
standing on one hand,
doing the fucking full lotus,
all the crazy shit that he could do
directly translated to him almost
immediately being a bad mother
fucker in Jujitsu directly.
Ridiculously.
Um,
and not just athletic,
but the dexterity of one
language informs the other
man.
You're wrong.
Jansen's movement wasn't wild,
but this is movement.
This is why I'm saying you're wrong.
It's all good if it works.
And how sign up for salsa classes.
Dan,
don't you remember what
football players were taking?
Balance?
Yes,
I did.
It did you sell side.
But why did it take
ballet or something to do
to get this ham hock and he's tied to
check this out.
Ladies.
Wear Yoga Pants.
Shoes.
Listen to [inaudible]
valley for two years.
You gotta you have time
to do all these things.
They enter school.
Why are you not 90 theater schools?
Shit,
you've done for five years.
I lived in the woods.
Mushrooms.
How
big acting school.
You have to take ballet acting school.
You must take ballet
and you have to perform.
Fuck you.
Okay.
That's like going to painting school and
learning how to like play video games
but not related and the tasting right now,
and I'm being dead serious.
I was a beautiful dancer.
I'm barefoot
ballet ballet's to do that video,
that video you did was
just hilarious of uh,
not unconventional dancer.
What was the name of it?
Um,
what the fuck was that video that you
did that where I was at [inaudible]?
No,
you had this crazy dance
video that you made.
I can't remember.
It.
Dammit.
It was hilarious.
She said,
oh,
just did this thing.
Take a look at it.
And I remember I took it home with back
when people that actually had DVDs.
Yes,
it is Brian Dancing.
It wasn't unconventional cancer.
It's not called word unconventional.
Like in know fuck on Orthodox dancer.
No,
no,
no inappropriate dances.
I think it was great.
It was a sketch that he,
it was ridiculous.
It was ridiculous as a guy just like,
it's okay to dance on a dance floor.
A great right.
We all agree.
Give me,
as long as you step into this
arena and you're on the heart,
it's all to get ridiculous,
but you can't do that shit when
you're waiting in line to rent a car.
Brian said,
sounds great.
Thanks.
I can't remember.
Remember,
I just remember there was
some inappropriate dancing
when I slapped the gambler.
I slap that Bob thing and I would
jump out and that sounds hilarious.
I did all kinds of weird stuff like that.
We were doing ballet and
then about two days into it,
so it was like we should
probably go catch him flip balls.
Yeah,
no shit,
no shit.
And that's where all this
movement dancing stuff.
Why don't you think lunges are
essentially in a lot of ways,
especially dumbbell lunges are very
much a movement exercise cause it's all
about balance and rigidity and
keeping your core straight.
They're like,
there's something about
like double Dumbbell lunges,
things along those lines
that they were you,
they help you go balls
as it was no heavy stuff.
Like,
yeah,
like if you're going to apply like an
explosive movement to a martial art,
there's no doubt about lifting weights.
Helps.
Right?
No doubt about it.
Like lifting weights.
If there was no weight restrictions,
you can do whatever you wanted and
lift as much weight as you want it.
There's a big difference from one 70 and
200 you mean there's a big difference.
You get like way stronger if
you get way more explosive,
you get,
it's beneficial in a applied situation.
Right?
Agreed.
That's movement.
Yeah.
It's not much different.
It's like you're talking about movement
with weights or movement with Moitai
like people.
There's a lot of people that say
training boy ties helped a Jujitsu.
I believe it.
It doesn't make sense,
but just kind of shit.
You have to do all this motions
you have to do in Moy Tai.
That's movement too.
I would also say timings with gymnastics.
What leads,
what leads one person,
like what with Hixon would lead him into
the other disciplines is that mindset
that that comprehensive minded
mindset constantly get better.
This foundation is so fucking good insane,
but also he was a student of
the Great Japanese Samurai.
Yes.
Their philosophy.
So I'm sure he read the book of five
rings and one of the things about the book
of five rings in and emphasize was
like taking in all sorts of different,
be soft,
like taking calligraphy,
do painting because the flexible
and the reason for that,
if you look at any great innovator,
they started with one discipline,
they started with one
discipline and then they,
when they studied other disciplines,
they were able to appropriate those
disciplines and come up with a new style.
They really will revolutionize a
new style by studying that style.
You branch out a young Hixon might be,
might be Alan Jobe in a young,
oh yeah,
Hanson is shot.
Good shot.
So he's from the long goal essentially.
He's,
you know,
from South America
twist head plus to have a real problem.
The real problem with that
Pussy Hickson was getting,
oh my God,
please bring him up.
I like to look at his,
he's getting supermodels.
Let's,
let's look again.
Let's like,
let's not bring up specific instance.
I think your a Jujitsu helps your
music and I think your music helps you
Jujitsu.
And I think as your
Jujitsu has gotten better,
you music's gotten better and
as your music's gotten better,
your Jujitsu,
Scott,
I think it'd be a coach.
I think they're all too,
cause you'd be red hot too.
When you get great at things like
especially like you specifically,
you're a guy who like one of the best
things about you creating 10th plaids
judges ever since I've known you,
like if you have an idea in your mind,
like there's a point you have to get
to like okay there's a spot over there
you've got to get.
So you have this crazy tunnel vision.
Well you'll figure out unconventional
paths to get to a point.
Like you,
you can block out a lot of like external
shit that a lot of other people don't.
You know,
they can't block out the can't fat.
They can't like tune in to the
finish line the way you can.
It's really interesting to see because
I think that applies to your music as
well.
I think it applies to everything you do.
And I think it comes for a lot of us.
I think it comes from like some fucked
up place where you didn't get enough when
you were a child and then
you detention or what?
Anything.
Love,
attention,
praise,
[inaudible] ship,
Camaraderie.
Also,
what's really important is like
I said this to him the other day,
I go,
dude,
you know,
he says,
don't spar.
You know why it's parked is it terrifies
me now I'm not good as far as you turn
this in to you and I was talking to,
I'm trying to explain to him.
No,
no.
What I'm saying is that you listen,
listen,
son of no,
this is the point I'm making.
Listen,
when you do something that you're
afraid of or that puts you on,
makes you uncomfortable.
I end up writing I think.
I think like when you do
another discipline that maybe
you're not even good at,
that scares you.
It'll open up channels in
your original discipline.
It will jumble your brain so you
come at things in a different way.
If you stay comfortable in and stuff,
you're,
you're most likely,
if you're going to create a field,
it's harder to branch out
and become more creative.
If you do things you're not that
good at that maybe you're scared of.
They churn that.
That caused you to stretch in other areas,
and this is the,
this is the argument for movement coaches.
When you do things you're not that good.
I had to put you in an in your,
in your step out of your comfort zone.
You'll probably get
better at your original,
better be good at everything else.
We'll probably hire a movement coach.
That's true.
Being Open minded.
I think four of us should get a timeshare
fucking gay where just four dudes.
I don't know.
Let's do it.
Christ,
this podcast every day.
Listen,
after all of our checks
get sick about bullshit.
Let's just get a fat house in the
hills and the movement coach every day.
We have a big house with
four branches where you know,
we don't have to
necessarily hear each other.
We just meet in the kitchen.
You know what I'm saying?
And just live like men don't live like
these bitches that we've become trapped
in this world.
This world of this is
when we get to be free.
We could be free like this all the time.
Yeah.
Oh,
gives it at the end of Braveheart.
that's
what I'm saying.
Open.
Say Pew,
Pew,
Pew
with a broke foot whips and
the actual injury was p baby.
I just a sprain.
He looks like the rocking.
Okay.
Yeah,
it looks like he's walking.
Okay.
It's a tough line on this.
And Susan Silva,
what do you think is,
I forgot this.
Shaye Anderson.
Um,
it's a very good fight at this
time and both of their careers,
it becomes interesting,
whereas like Anderson,
when he was dominating,
when he was like,
like right after he smashed jail son in,
in the second fight,
you would think like,
Whoa,
that's a,
that's a tough fight for Bisping.
The Andersons just in the matrix.
But Anderson comes off of,
you know,
like psychologically there's
two v brutal losses in a row.
One a loss for sure.
What a catastrophic injury.
Then he just fell off.
Yeah.
And then he gets by Nick Diaz,
but he gets humiliated.
Like Nick Diaz lies on his back and puts
his hands on his head and mocks him.
He's talking to him.
He's calling him a bitch.
Dude.
Nick Diaz was super respectful right up
until the moment they got in that cage.
And then he was Nick Diaz.
Yes.
It was all gone.
He's never fucking,
it's like that old fable about
the Scorpion and the frog.
The frog wants to get across
the pond and the Scorpion says,
or the Scorpion wants get across the frog,
the pond and the frog,
uh,
is in the water and his corporate says,
let me ride on your back.
And uh,
the frog says,
I won't do that if I do that,
you'll sting me.
He goes,
well,
if I did that,
we would both die.
I'm not stupid.
So the Scorpion rides on the frog's
back and halfway across the water,
he stings him and the
frogs like what the fuck?
And the Scorpion is like,
sorry.
It's in my nature.
Yeah.
Damn dog.
What kind of childhood stories
that you haven't heard?
The famous story.
They also use it.
They'll use it.
They'll see is in connection
with that 20 stings.
Him and a guy.
What's that?
I don't know the score.
That's a great,
that's a great allegory.
Well,
the Blue Red Riding Hood,
once upon a time
that your children in the words and you
legitimately had to worry about them get
eaten by wolves.
Yeah.
Moral these motherfucking
and story is this.
It's vegans are retarded.
That's,
that's the story of these
motherfuckers [inaudible] everywhere
because stay the fuck out of the woods.
Stay out of the woods.
The words,
there's a fucking wolf.
Yes.
And then don't trust strangers actually.
Yeah.
Well also number Numero
Uno mentally for sure,
because the person inside the house
and pretended to be his grandmother,
but the reason why they were always wolves
where there's little red riding hood
of three little pigs.
It was always wolves.
Wolves legitimately ate a lot of fucking
people and people seem to have forgot
about that.
Now we're all these assholes.
We need to bring back the wolf.
We need to make sure the Walter
like wolves will kill everyone.
You know,
they don't eat a lot of,
they eat some of what they killed.
Oh my God,
wolves are so prey driven that they
will kill whole herds of elk and not eat
half the meat.
I'll slap the fuck doing about German
German fairytales like Hansel and Gretel.
What happens?
A lady and old lady takes
him and she's a witch.
She puts them in a cage and
starts feeding them too.
What?
Plump them up so she can eat them more
or less stories don't trust even old
ladies.
Germans are like,
you're a stranger.
Sorry.
Also,
let's be honest about
like a long time ago,
a thousand years ago in rural areas
where food was scarce and people had
suffered through a lifetime,
you weren't going to survive the winter
and chaos and seeing murders and seeing
assault and rape and constant,
just the programming of person.
How much cannibalism
was going on back then?
A lot according to Steven Rinella,
like in this country.
I mean Steve,
we were talking about the other day
with the native Americans and Nez Perce.
Steve or Noah has the best
native American stories.
He's like,
he does,
he's a legit scholar almost.
I mean,
I don't think he would call himself that,
but he's incredibly knowledgeable on
American history and like what the Nez
Perce Indians did in the,
in the,
like the Great Lakes area.
They would eat a lot of cannibalism,
man,
a lot and filed the teeth down.
That was a crazy guy,
right in the history
of the missionaries.
There's a lot of documented evidence.
What that all was like,
yeah,
we got this from an Indian.
They were cannibals.
We have to kill them all because
there are cannibals won't,
by the way,
any problem might be honest.
Sometimes stories.
The ETJ they're going to eat.
We love that.
All the native Americans,
the hippies,
they were human beings.
Just like all of us.
Like all of us weren't any more noble.
They were no more noble than anybody else.
They were good people and bad people.
They were just as violent as,
hey,
the most violent people arguably could be,
could be white people.
Like what the Germans did.
It didn't.
White people,
man.
Well,
I think also like when you're dealing
with people in the Great Lake States,
the lights and fucking wipe it.
That's a horrific knockout mice,
the Roy Nelson Minataro knockout.
But um,
you know those people
were living in a horrible,
horrible climate like the,
the Great Lakes before the invention
of heat and it must have been so fun.
Yeah.
I mean people got desperado like,
you know,
we know about the Donner
Party in Colorado.
They get trapped in the mountains.
They had to eat each other.
That shit probably happened all the time.
And the Great Lakes,
they just didn't talk about it.
You're talking about
15 below zero recently,
right?
I wonder what part you eat first.
The legs just go right to the asshole.
That's the worst part first for you.
I take the chest,
I hit your chest.
Say Listen,
worst case scenario
meeting someone's asshole.
I'm a scoop it out with a sharp,
that's the last thing.
You Ain't a file a spoon with a,
with a fucking,
I'm not even going to pass on the shit.
You don't even want to like the
shit you have to hold on to,
you know,
I need to eat their shit.
I would eat their bowls in there.
Dick.
You know,
why take first testosterone?
Because that's what the raccoons
and the squirrels go after first.
There's a reason.
Think about that.
Now the ball,
that's how wolves
determine who's the alpha.
The alpha gets to eat the liver.
That's why there was a,
yeah,
there was a guy who did a,
a a whole,
um,
this whole,
like he's a documentary where
he lived with wolves and he,
he lived amongst them
and he had to fake it.
Kill.
He would have a kill there and he would
pack a liver inside of it and he would
pull the liver out.
He didn't in front of them and he had to
eat it in front of them and then we let
them eat.
But he's like,
no,
no.
This fucking van.
It's terrifying.
Yeah,
it's fucking terrifying.
Cause then here's,
here's the thing,
what happened?
He had a farm nearby that was
having problems with wolves and he,
this guy was a wolf scientist.
And so he would uh,
go there with these big gigantic
speakers that play wolf sounds.
Cause he had a scare off this one pack
of wolves with a new pack of wolves that
invade us instead of make it,
he had to make it scary enough.
So these worlds backed off.
It's all on video.
The scary thing is when the Alpha,
when there's a thing,
he came back,
the guy came back after a month and the,
there was a new wolf had taken over
and so the new wolf wanted to kill him.
So he had a whimper.
She had a whimper in front of this wall.
So he was recognized as the,
the old alpha and to avoid being killed,
which is standard.
It's normal.
Like a wolf would challenge and they
would fight to the death and the new alpha
would kill the or try
to kill the old alpha.
He came back close to die
because he was in his face growl.
Human involved in all that fucking shit.
The off the wall.
Oh yeah.
There's a whole documentary on it.
It's called living with wolves.
I think.
Here's the thing about it,
man,
they don't understand
that he's an unusual,
because they'd been with him since he was,
they were a baby.
See the whole,
I go the way that works.
He didn't just walk in.
It's a gigantic wildlife preserve and
this guy lives in the wildlife preserve
these Wolfe's.
Yes.
He knows for their whole life.
So they've been with him since he was,
you know,
like four or five years ago.
But they're fucking grown.
Dangerous has wolves now.
Shit.
It's amazing.
You have to find it.
Jamie isn't home living with wolves.
I've met.
It's probably on that.
I watched him with wolves.
I think I rushed it.
Some guy came in and said,
check this out.
I'm on a fixed,
his wolf problem.
Opry mentioned to me some dude who
was living with the grizzly bears.
Oh yeah.
That's crazy,
man.
He died,
got fucked up by the bears.
So they ate them.
One of the best,
uh,
like,
what am I confusing?
Grizzly man.
Best best documentaries ever.
It's a Werner Herzog documentary,
unintentional.
Coming up talking about that guy.
Oh,
there's another guy that lives it bears.
Yeah,
man.
He was like the real aggressive today and
then the thing he ate his asshole that
like the next day.
Well there was one bear
that they used on a movie.
They used the like some football.
I'm talking about bark the Brit.
Yeah,
that guy on 12th legs.
Yeah.
No shit reason.
No Shit.
The guy was just standing there doing
like they were doing some sort of drill
together and the bear just decided
terrorists throw to pull it off.
Course Beers are going to bear shit.
I of course agree with you.
What did you think was,
so I talked to a trainer.
I talked to this training with Perez.
He said,
well,
bears a worn yet about three
minutes before they're,
if they're having a bad day,
you got to step up and go.
What do they do?
They good day.
He goes,
they start clicking their
jaw Wunderbar starts winning.
Grizzlies starts clicking his jaws time.
If you just stop training,
alright.
And he's trans big cats.
They will warn you.
What is this?
Is this the same guy?
Dude?
Those are wild.
None on this isn't the same Guy Jamie.
Now,
this isn't the scientists.
The scientists was a younger guy.
Well,
this is another guy.
Just does the same.
Yeah.
I think that guys living with wild wolves,
that guys,
yeah,
Werner Herzog,
Werner Herzog.
It's like chills with them.
No,
it's not.
Werner Herzog,
Werner Herzog's grids,
grizzly man,
this guy's name is Werner
fruit or something like that.
Um,
it was a different guy and uh,
it was a really pretty positive.
It was a younger guy.
Oh Shit.
I'm going to get all into this now,
man.
It's amazing.
You know what?
I,
they have a really
sophisticated social system.
I don't know why.
You know what I paid her into lately?
Big Time.
Like I said.
Yeah,
they do.
Anyway,
keep calling quite by
making a murderer and all that.
I still haven't seen it yet.
I'm a rebel bro.
Shit's me.
I'll fucking walk wolves and bears balls.
Deep Harden with that man.
I'm obsessed with wildlife.
Absolutely fucking obsessed.
I'm obsessed.
I'm obsessed with rolling Netflix
documentary about the India and the Ganges
River.
No,
what's it called,
dude?
It's called like wild and India,
but it's on Netflix.
Wild Ganges River.
Why was insane.
Very dirty.
It comes from no,
listen,
it's not that they're,
this is the crazy part about it is all
that that river comes from the Himalayas,
all the ice and the glaciers or something
like that on Netflix about India,
but the part about the Ganges River,
it's a magical fucking river.
They sh they put debt,
they burn dead bodies in there.
They throw trash,
sewage,
everything.
But there's something they did.
It's called the wildest.
Wildest.
Yes.
There's something about that.
Water has so much mineral,
it's a composition that it,
it's like an antibacterial water.
It kills all the bacteria
and the pathogens.
They've,
according to this documentary that
could be full of shit on Netflix.
It's print.
They're saying that it's so,
there's so much sewage goes into there,
but it cleanses itself.
You can still drink it.
You can be down in the river.
People still drink,
cause my friend was a jumped in
and had an earache for two years.
Okay.
[inaudible] white crime.
Right.
A bit about the sooner
bands going to be fast.
It sounded bands is no joke.
I remember that.
I used to have Eddie
about the guy who's the,
they got killed in a boat.
There was a boat.
There was food diet with the Tigers.
Yeah.
They swam out to the boat and killed
these guys individually one by one and
dragged him back to the shore.
The tiger swam out to the boat.
I remember that you told me that this
documentary we talked about that they
couldn't.
That's the only spot on the world
and where tigers actively hunt human.
They love the taste of humans.
Slobber off while they say,
is that apple?
Had you ever go to India?
Oh,
I ain't gone,
but they got great documentaries about it.
Yeah,
I'll watch that show.
They've killed literally hundreds of
thousands of people over the last hundred
years.
Over the last hundred years.
Tigers.
Yeah.
They have some,
some nutty number.
Let's not the best way to
go over the last 200 years.
I think the number's like 300,000 I
quoted the number like honestly and
realistically in my comedy
special that was talking,
talking monkey's in space.
They fucking killed the killed this guy
dragged him to shore and then jump back
in the water killed another guy,
dragged them in,
short,
jumped back in the water,
killed another guy,
the frown.
They couldn't swim away.
These things are so fast,
they can swim faster than five guys
can row a boat at full speeds there
anything.
He's a great book.
Great book called the managers have,
come on,
read the medics,
tie Jason,
Jason,
dude,
the crocodiles.
Don't fuck with them.
Crocodiles and fuck with Rochelle to run
it from Roy Nelson like he was a tiger.
Right?
Well,
Roy Nelson is a dangerous dude.
Nelson throws fucking hammers.
You want to talk about a guy who
was always been known as a Jujitsu?
He thought it was fucking fired.
Eddie and I knew Roy Nelson back
when he was just big country.
Everybody called him big
country and he's a Jujitsu guy.
Oh that fucking haymaker
the mark layman days.
Yeah.
Are these guys are going to
get a Versace had contract.
He should.
Well,
if Versace was fucking smart,
I they would try to get it on
their chubby man dollars for real.
Is that Denmark?
Why?
Why does everybody have to be beautiful?
Roy Nelson in a fucking fat
suit with a cigar in his hand,
sick and this man haters.
What's on my arm hanging out
this and people love that guy.
I really believe absolutely 100% that
he's like under marketed by a lot of
companies.
Like companies should scoop that guy up.
Schlitz Schlitz
malt liquor.
She not even as a joke like that,
but just like he's a man.
First of all,
fucking man.
He has the most knockout bonuses
in UFC history for heavyweight.
Yeah.
He's a fucking man.
It's in the animal.
It's an animal.
We get real shot.
He has a grown man running from him.
Yeah,
I mean this motherfucker throws hammers.
Do you remember when he knocked
out Mitre on Jesus Christ?
Dude cameras.
He knocked out Nogueira like
he was a fucking paper cutout.
Is he the hardest guy that's ever hit you?
Yes.
Jesus Christ.
He was hot.
Damn.
Like Rochelle Rochelle,
Rochelle can take it.
He's like,
fuck you bitch.
Rochelle was about to get knocked down.
The grow shock isn't wrestler.
Yeah.
Was One
mistake.
Okay.
National Champ,
heavyweight heavyweight match jam.
It's similar as sumo wrestling.
He can be shitty about it.
It really is really,
really until Brock Lesnar's
in your division brought,
that was 20 years ago now,
but the whites that,
what's the difference between now and
then like a Brock Lesnar was around today.
Is He rebelling?
There's no proxies out there and I
don't know what's the exact college
wrestling?
I watched the finals
freak.
He's a silver,
a blonde silver back.
Is it evolution?
Are we seeing the last of the Viking DNA?
Cause he is a regular sized wife.
Guys are growing straight.
Emo Now.
Yeah,
probably he has a regular size wife.
I'm sure his children
would be fucking gigantic.
But while Amy was a pro wrestler,
right,
she was a,
he's wife.
She was a,
she was stable.
She was saying was sable
and Jude was fucking fine.
Beautiful.
He did well.
He did well for himself.
[inaudible] to jack off to middle school.
How dare you say that?
No,
it's a good thing
you don't do shit.
You fake fighting.
Oh,
how dare you.
It's true too.
Boy,
if you met him in an alley,
he's like one of the worst people
you could run into it for him.
He would rate me a brief exchange.
Let's be real.
He raped me and I have to do something.
I have to jump on his back.
Don't pry.
I'd have to pull them aside and say,
listen,
his kids are going to be freaks.
Kids will probably stole it from us.
So when his kids grow to
be about 18 years old,
we'll start getting nervous again,
but until
there's no price out,
she's beautiful.
I'm looking at,
well,
who is that dude that just
fought that kickboxer dude.
Um,
uh,
black gentlemen from an,
from,
was it from Africa in the UFC?
Yeah.
You're talking about the dude from France.
From France.
That's right.
He was like a shittier looking check.
Congo dreads.
Asti power.
Yes.
To power.
Sure.
Take him down.
Yeah.
Well he got taken down the first round.
Who was that?
What was tray Bree sable
though was the hotness?
I haven't,
I haven't talked about her forever.
Sable.
Okay.
If you can get like Gabby Garcia and
Shane car went to have a kid cause lawdy
Miss Kalata.
What would we have?
What will we have?
Shane Carwyn and Gabby Garcia.
Oh Shit.
You got a woman who's six foot four.
You periscoping you fuck no.
Was he doing periscope is no idea.
Shane car went and Gabby
Garcia have a baby.
You think that's the
ultimate super athletes,
bro.
Fuck that shit.
No,
no.
Shane Carwyn and Serena Williams.
Oh,
you're right.
You're right.
In a racial as well.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's just a lot of emotional power
to both sides combining together in one
furious in that kid to the lettuces.
Just send it to the loan only.
Don't make him rich and happy.
You send them just,
they might not make it
out of there though.
Nah,
they'll figure it out.
I don't know.
That's a rescue
you have to make more than one.
Do we get on this book is
your baby has this ridiculous,
what was that movie?
The guy who was born with a deformity.
You're talking about
the launch with share.
We share.
That's mask
fair guy.
The Bear Guy Meets Sulu the bear man.
Oh,
okay.
It's a new bear guy and his
face got ripped off too.
Did he get killed?
Oh boy.
Do you know Jamie are yet?
You guessing they kind
of deserve it though?
Yeah.
Find out if he got killed.
So it looks like the
bearing number B watermelon,
Huh?
Well,
here's the thing about bears,
man.
Bears can be a lot like dogs if
they're like really taken care of.
If you feed them and loved them,
like people have lived with bears
where they like swim with bears,
would you gotta be with them
for the time they were a baby?
They can never be,
never be feral.
And you,
you gotta be able to raise
them and give them love.
So they,
they sort of have to identify with you.
They have to give a precise date,
but the imprint on you,
but they're like a dog.
And a lot of ways,
I agree with you,
it's always a risk because you're
dealing with something that like one
generation removed was completely wild.
Like you could easily have a
grizzly bear where you are.
You're the mother.
Grizzly bear had a fight for its life
against a mountain lion that was trying to
kill this baby.
You know,
that's totally possible.
And then here it is,
like one generation later you got the
pop and it's living in your house.
Tell you write this cup.
I'd rather chill with those grizzly bears
than the sum of those chimpanzees and
Shit in my house.
That's good.
Call chimpanzees might decide to fuck you.
These are beers.
Just gonna rip my throat out.
Fucking shit wants to bust that.
None of my ass.
He's going to do it.
You know,
it's on the verge of suicide.
If you want to commit suicide,
then that might be a good idea.
You know what?
Since you're going to kill herself,
why not go fucking live
with lions saying that he,
you know what I mean?
See what happens.
And then if they kill you,
whatever you were going to kill yourself.
Anyways.
Guy In South Africa lives at 21 lions
and wrestles getting of mine as well.
Turn out great.
Yeah,
that works out.
Are you suicidal?
Call this number now guys.
Guys to do is we'll do whatever they can
to separate themselves from the pack to
scientists that are like,
they want to gain data that like you
gotta you gotta be suicidal to go into
those motherfucking dens.
Did Rochelle Catch Roy?
Is that what you meant
when he fell he slept.
I slept.
I'm surprised and I try and do that all
the time and I get embarrassed when I
like I'll go,
oh,
and some won't land and
I'm my own professional.
Like I'm at the fights calling the fight
and someone throws a head kick and it
doesn't land,
but it like,
looks like it's going to land
last minute.
It gets to,
I'm like,
oh my God,
but it's genuine.
I swear to God
folks got to slip when I
talking to when I yell out.
Like I don't,
I don't do that accidentally.
I mean,
I don't do that.
Uh,
artificially.
This looks like it
guys look like they're completely related.
Yeah,
definitely.
Same species,
exact same speech.
This isn't confusing at all.
You know,
good thing he has a beard
because I wouldn't remember.
I wouldn't.
I'd be like,
Huh?
I remember when Keith
Hackney fought a manual.
Yarbrough,
you'll do whatever you like.
Okay,
what's going on here?
These things,
these things are so not
similar in their size.
These two individuals that both it,
he's doing no show.
We'll show it looks like a
supermodel version of the mask.
Right?
[inaudible] sacred here.
How is that talking shit?
I said you look like a supermom
from the sheer shoes is my favorite show.
Yes.
Devin.
Eddie,
look,
that's terrible.
That's probably the [inaudible] per bottle
is better.
I'm going a joke and
say that I'm doing my,
like I said,
you better
say something,
man.
You're joking.
Social Berg,
it's going to cost Roy Nelson this fight.
The Karma of your joke is so
it's a compliment.
It might've caught over Wales.
Here's a trivia question.
Who is the accurate?
He's a real dude.
Come on,
man.
That's not makeup.
That's a real dance.
No,
I thought that was a no,
no,
no.
It's Eric Stoltz.
No,
no,
that's Eric Stoltz.
Yeah,
sure.
Got Derek Brennan.
How bad that make you feel?
I was like,
oh no,
no.
I knew it was never installed.
Here's a,
here's a little Jiu Jitsu trivia powder.
Remember that dude,
Sean Patrick
Jujitsu.
Legit blackout under Shawn Williams.
Yeah,
Sean Williams.
Henzel Gracie black belt
after powder.
Well,
here's the deal.
The Guy who,
the guy who directed powder
was a guy who is like,
there was some controversy about some
alleged child molestation charges,
which made powder or really weird
movie was powder was kind of like,
uh,
like a nambla love story
to a lot of people.
There was a hole about like
that guy he got in trouble.
The guy who direct like not,
it wasn't a little thing like he
got in like real criminal trouble.
I do not remember we shit.
I do not remember the
specifics I'm going to watch.
I don't think there is,
but there's no fight out.
Jamie flipping here.
Hold on a sec.
Here we go.
Barry Crimmins was when
the talking about it,
I believe they're on the case of Netflix.
Barry Crimmins,
was he talking about that?
He was talking about AOL.
Barry Crimmins was talking about AOL,
how child molesters were
selling things to AOL,
but Barry Crimmins did
comment about that guy on a,
was it on a podcast?
Was It on Twitter?
I thought that's how I heard about it.
Maybe you might be right.
You might be right.
I had known about it before that I'd
read a are there was a big article
that was about it,
I want to say like two years ago,
but uh,
yeah.
Barry,
of course,
if you don't know Barry Crimmins is,
he's a Boston comedy legend and he had
a Bobcat Goldthwait documentary called
call me lucky and it's about his,
he'd getting molested when he was a kid.
It's horrific,
man.
He was two years old.
He was four years old
and it's babysitters.
Boyfriend would fuck him.
God Damn.
Why didn't you bring the podcast?
Dude?
You got to see it.
I'm fine to me.
Call me Lucky's and amazing dot.
Here's the guy.
Look at this.
Victor Salvo loves terrorizing.
Semi-Naked use.
That's a scary,
no shit.
[inaudible]
that's from 2012 from vice.
Take her shirt off.
Ready?
What do you mean terrorizing
bottoms on tops off.
Exactly.
Take a pair of pants up.
Move around.
I might kick you.
I don't know.
I might Damn Royce go for the shake.
Kill now.
Three for three year before it was cool.
He's a hipster for a take down.
Did not get it.
Roy Roy's wrestling's underrated Liquidia
to Barnett that he has a loss on his
record.
That I think is one of the most unfair
standups I lost against our Lawsky side
control working on a Kamora.
He has a full double wrist lock.
He has the double Russell.
He doesn't have the lock right
cause he has to get it locked.
Turned behind the back on a song guy.
It's a Camorra's an interesting move
because Marcello Garcia doesn't like to do
it because he thinks
it's a strong man move.
He doesn't,
he doesn't incorporate it.
He's all about chokes.
He's all about whatever he
does has to work on everybody.
When we wrote that,
nothing wrong with that at all.
Weird way to,
there's a he,
he,
you know,
he doesn't believe in any kind of chokes
with our men like triangles or Darcy
has happened is that guy,
but I understand.
I understand.
Really,
totally understand that a a shit.
If he only focus you take that time.
Everybody has the same
amount of time to drill.
Everyone has the same time.
Everyone has 24 hours in a day.
Everyone has a life.
Everyone did that.
Everyone has the same on the fucking time.
Generally,
what are you going to do with that block
every day when you break it all down,
what are you going to do with that block?
If you say,
why don't you save all that time
for shit that works on the big guys?
If it works on the big guys,
it's going to work on the small guys,
so let's just work on that.
There's nothing wrong with
that at motherfucking all.
That's really it.
That's genius.
Me Personally,
I like working on everything that works
on guys that have like 15 pounds on you.
You know what I mean?
Because you're going to be rolling
out a lot with guys that are your uh,
your size and maybe as long as it works
on guys that have a little weight on
you,
I'm into those most.
To me that's a legit move.
If that works on a guy that's
around your size at a high level,
I want that in my character
actually just talking about that.
He would work on chokes.
He said Tokes always work,
whereas other stuff,
but there's a difference between,
there's a difference
between a arm in chokes,
like Darcy is Japanese like tires arm
and give teens and then straight net
trucks like Marcella teens and all
these weird little fucking things like
Rothwell on,
on Barnett.
There's all these Ninja chokes and shit.
There's about 23 motherfucking ways to
squeeze the neck to make a motherfucker
tat,
you know what I mean?
So all those take special
time to get good at.
Just because you're good at one of the
23 makes it has nothing to do with are
you good at this one or
are you going to that one?
You got to spend the same
amount of time on that shit.
It might give you a little boost.
If you're really good this
one then you'll really,
you'll get really good at this one
quicker than a guy who's not good at that
one.
But generally you've got to spend time
and all these chokes to master any,
let me ask this for,
I forget who was that.
There was one choke that I
saw only once in the UFC.
It was a choke like Gogo Plata by a
kid who was a tiger showmen student.
Nick Nick something or another it the UFC.
Yes.
He had some crazy choke and he said that
he invented it while it was going on.
He's like,
I'm venting it in the fight.
Um,
I have no idea what that is.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
I know what I'm talking
about but I don't remember.
I couldn't show you.
I showed him techniques
all the Goddamn time.
None of my shit.
I should have videotaped
that cause that shit gone
take new shit.
Nick Pace.
Yes.
He did some crazy.
See if you can find a submission because
there was some weird legs and Michigan
Trump,
I can show you.
Well I remember it was something to
zoo with a Shin across the neck by the
guests.
It was a joke.
It was some weird choke that had to do
with some weird like Alma Plata type set
up and he wound up in some position with
his Shin underneath this guy's choke
and underneath this guy's
neck in an unconventional
way that I don't necessarily
remember.
I'd have to see it again.
But I remember saying if you done that
before and he said that was the first
time he did it,
ever did it.
Is there,
is there a huge difference between guys?
Crazy.
Is there a huge difference?
Really good guys now and 10 years ago.
Oh,
Jujitsu wise,
like all different techniques.
That's like saying is there a difference
in standup comedy now in general as in
the 80s come on in the 80s of his
co there's really got them right.
You know what I mean?
Same Day,
same
look up behind you.
That's the choke nick pace
going to show us to it.
Why is it looks so crappy,
Jamie?
See you look at this.
He grabs it like this.
He throws the leg over the neck,
shoots under like this and he
grabs his ankle gun show control.
That's called gun,
but he chokes him from here.
Yup.
I got a guy,
Ben Eddy who does this ship.
So all the time
Dan came up with this on the
fly in the UFC dam and um,
how many,
you know,
he calls it the pace choke.
I don't,
I hair is great.
I do want to do that.
Eve Joe's cow.
Now check out.
He always has really legit
whose style is based off.
That said it looks nice,
but I'm going to show control.
Spend a lot of times.
That's a,
that's an atomic green.
Those guys taught Tiger
Schulman for a lot of children.
Those guys were
giant karate chain in um,
the east coast in New York all the time.
Like you both vehicles.
They didn't think of him as legit,
like necessarily because they thought,
well,
most giant karate schools aren't legit.
Yeah.
However,
they are legit.
Me Think Uriah Hall,
this fucking kid,
nick pace came from there.
I'm that guy who won last,
Frankie Rivera,
the guy who won last week
against a Uri Alcantara.
He's from there.
Jimmy Rivera.
James Rivera.
There's a lot of fucking really high
level guys from Tiger Shellmans.
Tiger shot with Uriah Hall is look,
his kickboxers standup is ridiculous.
It gets karate skills.
Fucking ridiculous that that spinning
back kick to the face that he called gay
guard with.
He's nasty.
That's all tiger showmen man.
It's amazing.
And this nick paste kid,
it's like they were one of
the few like big name schools.
That was a whole chain that
became like a real legit gym.
That's cool.
Karate chain number one karate chain.
Maybe there's others that did it.
I'm sure there are.
But Tiger shellmans was a
straight dominant karate
chain and when they saw the
unfold,
they were like,
okay,
we adopt,
we need some of that.
We need someone that's a tiger.
Schellman is uh,
openminded modern.
Another way to look at it.
Do you want me to look at as you have
it that big of school and they're always
going to be some superstars
who are going to come through.
No,
no,
no.
It's,
their training is really good.
It's not just that would most
other marsh martial arts,
most of the traditional martial
arts associations didn't evolve.
Tiger shellmans was all about evolution.
Most,
most Roy one traditional martial arts
associations are not into evolving because
the people at the top,
they're fucking lazy and cause they
would have to learn all this new shit.
You don't want to do it.
Who does this?
Who gets on top of a top rope,
pulls his shirt up and rubs his,
the homer Simpson
tough after a decision.
Steep Amy.
Oh,
choose the bay.
Got that new girl.
Hey,
easy dude.
Got,
damn it.
It's the wine.
He's a handsome guy.
I got Steve Bay is a very handsome
man.
[inaudible] minutes on Allen Gabon.
And you're going to talk
about Steve as a handsome,
handsome.
Let's be honest.
And this is,
uh,
this is one of the least heavy
fight companions ever after.
We've barely pay attention as I tried
to play bigger than does this the gayest
one?
Never Brian's here.
It gets somewhat,
I can't help it.
The dream about your
boyfriend can hear that
it was that the only job?
He's the only one so
far.
The only dream.
I can't wait for Connor dos.
Anjos what do you think
God is bigger than dos?
Anjos how about that?
How about percents?
What's up with that?
They say that.
Oh,
he didn't.
No we didn't.
Okay.
Cause that's what it says time.
I have a hard time.
I think he,
what he said was,
I have a hard time seeing
Connor win this fight.
I'm paraphrasing.
He's like,
he's being honest.
He's being honored.
It's called honey.
What did I say?
Listen man.
You cannot neglect the skills of dos.
Anjos yeah,
it's a tough fight.
I,
when I look at dose on Joe's,
I look at a fucking beast,
man.
The way he put away Benson Henderson,
the way he put away Donaldson Roney
the way he beat the fuck out of Sergio
Pettis or excuse me,
Anthony Pettis.
He's something special,
man.
Dude,
I can't think of a worst
matchup for comment,
but comments.
We've talked to colors.
He thinks that it's a legit,
he goes,
ah,
he's just like Josie Aldo,
but shittier version.
Do you think he's really trying
to start his own promotion?
Do you think that's legit?
That's,
that's bullshit.
Get
restless real.
I think so.
Here's the power.
He's actually saying,
did he actually say he's going
to start its own promotion?
Listen,
man,
if I was Conor Mcgregor,
why would I work for the UFC?
After awhile I would go,
I'm just going to do
the Conor McGregor show.
Take that shit in the road
with all the best comments.
Real,
real.
I wouldn't guys know.
I don't know.
I would imagine if Conor McGregor has
a contract that would allow him at a
certain time to no longer be with the UFC,
he could do whatever the fuck
he can take the spar with him,
but here's the question.
Why would he,
why would,
there you go.
It's those last two
fights on that main event.
Ghost him.
What would you say that command Nunez is?
No girl.
Let's not talk about that right now.
Let's let's what?
What I'm saying about Connor is that
Connor is a fucking legit superstar,
but the UFC made him a superstar.
Like the UFC is the perfect vehicle.
They've got everything down.
The promotion,
the management,
the way it's all set up.
The way the fuck the
marketing is on point.
It's on another level.
If you go to some other organization,
good luck running a smooth ship.
What happened to affliction?
What happened to elite x,
Z,
what happened and strife for bottom line.
The bottom line is Grier calm.
Conor McGregor would be unknown to the
world and Ireland training in a boxing
gym.
If it wasn't for the u s 100%
of remember that she ever sent,
he's got the UFC made him famous.
Oh,
green [inaudible] deserves the money.
It was a cooperative venture.
There's no either or.
They're not mutually exclusive in their,
their,
their amount of success.
That was dependent upon their actions.
They both benefit from no,
no,
but no.
Make no mistake about it.
The UFC,
would it always be big?
Yes,
but always be big.
If there was never a Connor,
the UFC would be just as been,
but never as big as with a guy like that.
If you want to be as
big as what that guy is,
you need econom McGregor.
So the only way it happened,
no doubt about it.
Or Rodney?
Always.
Yeah.
I've always been fascinated with Connor.
Maybe GSP today,
maybe GSP today.
Why would he says I think the UFC
today is bigger than it's ever been.
I think she has a young GSP today.
If he was a champion,
goddammit,
girls would be there.
They're fucking damp panties would
be filling up 100,000 seat arenas.
Yeah,
he's a stud.
He's CSP was in his prime,
like when he was like when he beat Bj
Penn for defending his title when he was
in his prime.
If Bj,
if the UFC was,
I think the UFC is probably,
I mean I don't know how many more
people watch it now than then,
but as far as like being well known,
it's way more well known.
I agree way more.
What about Bj Penn coming back?
What the fuck?
Amazing.
That's crazy.
Right?
Part of me.
He went to fucking Greg Jackson.
God,
he thought about it.
He's sitting there and fucking on Hilo
chill on the volcanoes outside the
fucking window.
He thought about it and he knew it.
He came back.
What did he fucking do?
He goes to Greg Jackson.
I mean,
he did the best fucking thing possible.
he could have went to Aka can.
I went to trial.
Tracy has a fight attention,
but
he decided to go to the one
of the top fucking schools.
But Jackson is not a bad goddamn choice.
The best choice.
Well,
it's one of like five best choices.
Eric Holt,
Delfi Arrow down in the lions.
That's a best choice
you've got for Rasa Hobby,
who is probably my first choice,
or one of them would be my number one
him or least her bowling as a striking
coach.
You mean everything coach
or a mastermind mastermind
though I think.
I think that working number
one mighty mouse is coach,
so you're right.
I'm mad human.
For us,
a hobby to me are commensurate.
I think they're exactly the same level.
They're both wizards.
I was talking about those guys.
They're masters.
Matt Hume had more MMA
fights I think for us.
Had some,
a lot of kickboxing fights.
But for us it's like nasty on the ground
and he's a super genius when it comes
to like his analytical mind,
the way it breaks down fights.
He breaks down street fights cause
youtube videos where he breaks down.
Yeah,
it breaks down how this guy came
out of guy and he got cracked.
This guy with a left hook
and he explains the footwork,
draws it in a diagram.
He's also a young smart as fuck.
He's younger and he's been through it.
Like he came up with everyone.
It was the coolest fucking thing he did.
He just put out a video or he's testing
guard work and ground and pound on
guards.
What guard works best for granted.
He did this shit.
He put it on Youtube,
he put it up.
So he had him,
him,
Gary Tilden and I think Gordon Ryan,
they had like some dude jumped with,
with boxing gloves,
jump in the Gar and start pounding them.
And,
uh,
and in the video,
the guys on the bottom,
whether it was for Gary telling
him or I think it was Gordon,
I don't fucking know that third guy was,
uh,
but they were just wrecking
the guy on top of leg locks.
Uh,
a bunch of different things.
It was like a revolutionary
experimentation.
Uh,
one of the smartest
things you could ever do.
The only thing I think version two,
he needs to,
I think we should add,
uh,
there's different scenarios
and ground and pound,
it's not always,
it's not always the same ground and pound.
Sometimes the guys on top,
he doesn't want even be on the ground.
So if you're not holding
him on the ground,
he's going to stand up and back out.
You have to have that,
that scenario to what happens.
And that's what God is best for.
A guy that's on top.
And your guard,
you must have pulled guard because
he didn't try to take you down.
He wants to stay on to sleep.
So as soon as you open your guard,
he's going to back out and he's gone.
So what guard is best for that scenario?
And there's another scenario also,
you have the scenario where
the guy is getting beat.
Your opponent is getting
beat up on his feet.
So he's taking you down at will and you
have to deal with the guy who's trying
not to let you stand up.
So I think a version two of those ground
and pound experimentation to figure out
what's the best guard.
I think that's my 2 cents.
But what the fuck do I know?
I don't know.
But the fact that for Ross actually did
that it he's already experimenting on
what is the best guard
for ground and pound.
That's brilliant.
I love it
for m and an MMA that says Nma,
he makes his UFC debut,
but I could've sworn and he's
trying to bet on this main event.
Son.
I'm trying to,
uh,
you want to break down the garden?
You make a good point,
Eddie.
And you know one another good point.
Ryan Callahan talked about for Breeshia
over dooms guard and he was like none of
our ground and pound worked
on them with King Mo,
who's a nasty wrestler
king most like world class.
We need more of those films that we
need honestly on a consistent basis.
Here's the thing though,
Eddie,
I think there's only like
five guys who can do that.
I mean that's one of,
that's how high in regard
I hold for us to hobby
ridiculous.
He's just a real martial arts wizard.
Super Smart Guy.
You're talked to him and
have conversations with them.
Tell me what that slide.
It's a,
he honestly set the blueprint
for everyone in Denver.
Like Shane Carwyn,
myself,
Nate Marquardt in the blueprint for GSP.
He had them do an all
this different stuff.
A lot of genius.
Like what kind of Shit?
Like walking on logs.
No.
Does he know that shit
playing when I was a kid,
you know,
aligning with rocks.
A lot of the drilling a lot.
He would have George drill a ton more
than we would drill instead of just
sparring.
No drilling a on the pads
and shit to movement started.
Worst case scenario where
we weren't doing that,
he's a legit genius.
I think that's one of the biggest
mistakes that people make is too much
sparring.
Even in Jujitsu,
I was talking to a buddy of mine who's
a purple belt about this and he's like,
he hurt his hip and he had to get
a hip replacement surgery and uh,
you know,
he's like rh,
he's like in his late forties and he,
and he's a very successful businessman
and he went from there to going back to
training again.
But once he healed up,
he's doing like drills and he's like,
man,
I'm telling you,
you just from doing all these drills,
my Jujitsu has gotten much,
much better because now he's constantly,
constantly improving upon
his data patterns pattern.
Yes.
Really the only pattern chunking you
were talking about Henner like a good
Henner Gracie is like pattern
chunking this whole life.
He just understands that way.
Pal boxing the patterns and mixing
them all up and it shows taekwondo.
So get John Hendricks body,
he looks fit
now.
Johnny Annex beat Tyron Woodley.
What do you say?
NCAA.
How's he look?
Johnny Hendricks looks amazing.
It looks slim,
right?
Yes.
He doesn't look a at all like he
hadn't any sort of a weight problem is
underweight this morning.
Or when they weighed in,
he was underweight the morning.
That's the French guy.
This motherfucker,
Woo.
What's his name?
Francis spins make that larger and go,
no,
no man.
He's a beast.
He's got some serious power.
Yeah.
And a good defense on the ground too.
When he got taken down,
the dude didn't do shit to them.
You may be friends,
but he's west African sir.
Oh,
for Shoah.
He's gigantic to stop doing that.
And I was,
I was interviewed.
I'm like,
hi,
can I interview over here?
Like he,
I went to interview him and he
decided he wanted to walk away and go,
uh,
see how the guys feeling after
he beat the fuck out of him.
Come like,
I'm okay.
I'll just be over here.
You do your thing buddy.
What a man.
He fucked that dude up.
I don't know who the fuck you.
Fuck.
I got a tiny time.
I don't know if the guy had
fought and I felt like the
look at Joe Silva book where
he comes up to these guys.
Oh my Lord.
But he holds their faith.
Listen,
he holds there.
Joe Silva,
he's a great guy.
Just needs mushrooms in a
fucking reality check by shrubs.
Are you reality check Brendan?
I think an ass whooping.
I'm kind of saying,
oh,
how dare you.
It was an I like Joe Silva.
I have never had any ill
dealings with Joe Sova.
He is my friend.
I enjoy him as a human being.
I do not know what the fuck went
down with you and Joe Silva,
me,
any fighter.
You bitches need to work that
shit out on your own bad.
No,
I'm good.
Now.
Up In another dimension.
You decide to come back and get a fucking
do it and you got to come back one
more time.
You're going to make a comeback.
What camp do you join and
what is your strategy?
It's hard to turn down muscle farm
with least her bowling right now,
but I'd probably go tristar.
I like muscle farm for
a couple of reasons.
One.
It's a big new facility.
Everything's super state of the
art and it's got some momentum.
A lot of dudes are gravitating
towards their leaster Elliot Marshall,
you know,
Duane Ludwig is in cahoots.
You know,
there's a lot of other
really good striking coaches.
You've got Brandon Thatch,
you've got his click way to there
now and the way it's happening,
it's happening right?
The guy who's running it now,
he's a student of mine and he,
he always wanted to,
uh,
he was very successful in
the supplement industry,
very,
very successful and his
passion was to build an
MMA two years ago,
years ago.
Here you go.
Here we go.
We got involved.
We had a fight with Danny Sanchez and
quite who ate it was the craziest part of
her plan.
Drinks,
Hendricks and Thompson is about to start
and we got to pay attention to this
shit.
This should support first of all,
Hendricks.
You're right.
Any predictions?
Hendricks was fantastic.
I don't know how if one of always
got to solve that wrestling,
but he never looked like that.
He looks so fit.
He's got to solve that wrestling.
Well,
he fucked up in the Tyron Woodley fight.
He didn't make weight.
Look at this fucking side stance.
Stance show unusual.
So epic,
and here's the thing about Stephen
Thompson is that he's been training a lot.
Wrestling has gotten a lot better and
he's not worried about being taken down.
He'll get taken down by Johnny Brian Hall.
He might get taken down,
but they might not with the
right hand caught Ncaa Chana.
It's hard to deal with it.
You're right.
It is hard to deal with.
You know what else had to deal
with 57 and o and kickboxing.
It's super hard to deal with.
Dude,
see,
I tried to Johnny's wrestling.
I tried hard Johnny's wrestling.
So tough
watching it.
Let's just watch it.
We were,
I know what the fuck is going to happen.
Talk.
You might be right,
but you're,
you're,
you're saying what's definitely
going to happen while it's happening.
That seems really ridiculous.
Same probability.
The rest.
That's how I sound.
I sound like a wizard.
I'm a little psychic dude.
I see things.
Exactly.
One second before that happened.
This is the worst kind of
commentary everyone was saying.
Imagine if we did
commentary like this sale.
Worse going to have
different shit is happening.
Yeah,
you got no dick tell he's not even taking
them down to tempted him right now.
Cool.
Countering countering counter counter.
A lot like mine,
like mine.
[inaudible]
to the face to telling you.
There's very few guys that could avoid
the take down like him and have these
kinds of skills.
It's a completely different
kind of leg dexterity.
Nasty dude.
He used to fight in that Chuck Norris.
Oh,
Johnny Hendricks is in a world.
He's getting lit up.
He's getting lit up like Thomas Tryna
do some shit that Hendricks has not seen
before.
It's hard to get a sprite.
It's hard to get a sparring partner.
I'm going to find a guy like him now.
He is one of the elites in
American kickboxing freak.
Look at him,
man.
He fights like a snake.
Oh sure.
To deal with so much taller,
tall.
It's not looking so much taller.
It depends on who you're looking for.
If you look at for Thompson,
it's looking excellent.
Yeah.
It's looking great.
Hundreds is isn't a bad situation.
Just trying to throw that
kick and he's getting caught.
He's getting timed.
He's in a terrible situation.
He says,
Rhonda Rousey Hall.
Look at the switch,
kick jumping,
switch,
kick jumps with the left
and kicks with the right,
right hand on the chin.
God Dog to lighten them up and no,
no relented.
How tough is Johnny Hendricks?
Doesn't even look like he's getting hurt.
He just keeps coming forward.
Look,
one wonder boy comes out
to do this to everybody.
How about that?
I've said that for a long time.
I think he beats Robbie Lawler.
I'll call it now.
He's learning how to fucking fight
MMA the same at the same level that he
learned to be this elite kickboxer.
Did I wash them in that
Chuck Norris thing?
Remember the World Combat League
with graphite and that bowl?
He was
honest,
tough.
He thought I was a fan of that.
Chuck Norris kickbox.
He was the champion
guys.
Hey.
Oh my God.
It's one of the best guys in it.
Johnny's covering.
Well,
damn,
I didn't know that.
Caught with two
zero zero crushing the head.
He's talking to him saying,
Oh God,
God,
title shot
saying it.
Oh,
look at this.
He can't even walk.
Oh no,
he's doing the karate
kid who he's married to.
We try to kid.
Oh my God.
He double got me.
Thought it was her.
Oh Shit Dude.
He fuck.
Fuck it.
Hey,
condom crown.
Here's his movement.
His karate,
he has minimal footwork.
Movement is just like
doing all those movements.
Drills with karate and you
see the way he does hips.
I guarantee McGregor.
We'll never say the 70 pound belt.
This is looking good to me.
I'll never say that.
You don't want to fight this guy
being precision.
Oh Man.
Appreciation though.
The precision knew it.
Bam,
Bam or Johnny Man,
this the difference in the giant.
He nodded at him,
look at it.
It's no.
He nods at them.
He's like,
Yup,
you got blue dude.
He got lit up or take him down.
He couldn't get taken.
This is the former champion who's gone
through the best camp of his life.
He's in the best shape he's ever been.
He comes in,
they're motivated and he gets torn apart.
Title shot apart by a gene
has to be a title shot.
We were witnessing this,
those separately.
Fuck of evolution.
First of us,
I'm a cheetah,
but we needed another one.
We needed another one.
Machida was like,
okay,
it's a special one.
It's still not karate
now we see it for sure.
The way,
listen
guys,
this is one round.
You can do Woodley in him
for the fucking title.
Hip Robbie Lawler.
A little bit of a break man through
a war with Carlos candidate karate.
Karate is are those
toxin Tom Lawler come on.
So on.
Wouldn't you want to see him?
I think that's what I'm saying.
It's hard to take
Woodley's title shot away.
It's very hard.
Yossi roles.
I do,
but I'm saying six in a
row in a sense of fairness.
If we want to get a sense of fairness,
it's a very difficult,
he's going to out strike everybody,
but how would you,
how much would you like
to see him versus Damien?
My,
Oh,
he's going to strike everybody.
I'd like to see him fight.
Can't take him down.
I
wonder if he kicks Damien.
My
conduit would be fine.
No,
I've been predicting the rise,
the Wonderboy for awhile.
Karate had won that fight.
That's all one bad fight.
We,
he's over two years ago he was overtrained
against Matt Brown Brown and since
then he's been dominant and
getting better every time.
And he was smart.
He's a one second that he goes and trains
the 185 pound champion is one of the
grittiest fucking wrestlers in the game.
He goes for Weidman's camp.
Weidman's a bigger guy and
he learns how to survive.
Well,
people,
a lot of people don't know Stephen
Wonderboy Thompson got his start from GSP.
GSP was fighting.
Carlos condit brought,
want to bully in,
I don't know how they met,
brought him in and then uh,
he sent him to Denver to train with Nate,
myself,
all the guys.
And he was just fucking everybody up.
Meanwhile,
how about this speed?
This guy,
one of the most marketable guys ever.
The nicest guy.
So like legitimately the nicest
friendliest guy you'd ever want to meet.
Clean cut doesn't look like some murder.
I hope you have your book shot here.
Like,
look at him.
He's going to thank God.
Thank God.
Hmm.
Jesus Christ.
His kid's good.
He's religious or something.
This guy came up to you,
had a club and said,
I used to fucking a bad ass strike.
I'm going to stop.
I'm going to go to church
and get better at fighting.
We're trying to get into the cage.
He's his hands to set
it up for the take down.
This guy's a fucking listen patiently.
That front leg side kick,
dude.
You see the extension
fuck routes like mine?
Yeah.
Well be better if it wasn't lefthand
Colby like yours.
You shut the fuck up.
He's a sniper or how fucking sniper.
Look at that.
Right uppercut.
No one's ever be Johnny
Hendricks like that too.
Not like that.
Look at that.
Right kick to the body on the way out,
Johnny.
So fucking tough though.
He's so,
oh Jesus
will.
Come on,
man.
You got to give it up.
He's a genius.
He's amazing.
Amazing.
Hashtag Callen called it.
That's the course.
I called it too.
I got my fucking barbell jeans on.
I will fight.
You were a genius tonight.
Every climb.
I was tired and I woke up.
He was writing
was on fire tonight.
Yeah.
You said he's a genius.
He was right.
We only have five minutes left.
Oh,
we did.
We tell you why he put everybody on
notice badly or these things timed.
It was a first friends here that's here.
Johnny.
Johnny's a man.
Let me here.
Turn
this out.
We go over to my hair.
It wasn't any panelist
off of him very well,
so that was something he did burn.
Well
man,
hats off.
He was the better man.
That's a man right there.
You didn't eat the old Morgan.
I was going to say,
besides,
you did an awesome job.
[inaudible].
You know what,
man?
That's fine because that
just shows his character.
Johnny,
Johnny.
Johnny Hendricks is a man.
Awesome.
If he's a man,
he's the best.
He's the nicest guy on Fiverr.
You had to find a fucking monster who
strikes has been striking since he was
three years old.
Sign up.
Nobody's fine.
What is fighting right now?
He's fighting a wonder.
Boys figured out how to stay standing.
Yeah.
He's figured out how to do it in where
he's gotten so comfortable with it.
They can get loose.
That was the total level
higher than everybody else's.
How you,
this is how you'd be dramatic
when you say is watch this.
No.
Hey,
did you know what he
was fighting the future
and that's all you gotta say it brother.
Yeah,
but no one's going to give
you that amount of time.
The format.
Why the pause for people.
Everyone dreamed of jumping back and shit.
You don't have that type of that.
I can't pause.
How does a wolf den son turned out?
I know are talking about fucking all
these like details and these guys,
I've never heard of it and I was like,
ah,
I can't find it.
Oh,
I was trying to keep an opening for wine.
I was trying to give you
prompts of your wine,
but I was,
I was kicking when you told
me and talked about that.
I mean,
you know,
you're just sabotage
us are off the charts.
Not Bad.
Right?
You're not mad.
Oh,
your wind skills are off the charts.
You know as much about wine is my
business manager who's got a fucking wine
cellar in is high.
I pay attention to those dudes.
Really?
I'll sit in a wine or a wine store
and talked to the guy for hours.
I,
yeah,
my wife has just dragged me out.
I'll call my friend Matt.
I'll call him from like anywhere.
I'll be like,
all right dude,
I'm in some cabernets right now.
I'm gonna read you some shit.
Yeah,
this is the expensive shoes.
This isn't any good.
Just just tell me which of the good one.
And he'll go,
oh,
that's a good one.
[inaudible] 97 95 is a better year,
but 97 is not bad to go to counseling.
One tool has good one.
Who?
Dude from tool.
Oh fuck yeah.
Got good one.
He definitely does.
As far as if you ever had Mainers wine,
it's delicious.
Who's Maynard Maynard Keenan
purple belt in Jujitsu,
by the way,
from tool.
He was the one I was talking about before
when I was talking about my friend who
injured his hip.
I just didn't want to namedrop.
Oh.
And he's a,
he owns could do.
So it's really good.
He does everything.
If he does anything,
he does it well.
He does it a black belt level.
Yeah.
You know,
you'd sooner a tool.
He makes fucking
fantastic back on the mat.
Wow.
Drilling.
He's,
you know,
he's my age.
Great music.
Yes.
He's a beast.
Like an intellectual.
A,
he's a,
he's a no bullshit kind of a guy.
And he called me up because I had that
a primal guy on Mark Sisson and uh,
he got a lot of things right.
But apparently when he was talking wine,
uh,
Maynard was like,
Eh,
stay in your lane son.
Yeah.
He's like,
we don't use 87 different chemicals.
you guys,
we need to use some natural shit.
Like yeast.
Yeah.
Maybe.
And you know,
maybe some tannins.
Fine.
A lot of times,
Remarkably Sam,
it was Christ Wonderboy is good.
Good God.
He's a snake.
Madness.
Not to be a dick.
I'm just saying this from since 1986
remember back in the day way he moves
to welterweight in the world.
In the first round.
He crushed them in the first round.
Two that we might be looking
at the champion right there.
We really must have been saying what
Robbie Lawler's Goddamn ferocious.
That mother fucker knocked out
knocked dot Melvin malleable
matchup for Robbie.
You might be right,
but Johnny Hodges to the worst
matchup you might be right.
But there are,
I believe there's a difference in the
amount of danger that Robbie Lawler we'll
put himself in versus the amount
of danger that Johnny [inaudible].
Boy,
I'm just saying the amount of danger
he'll put himself in trying to hit him.
Robbie Lawler would take some crazy ass
fucking chances and do some explosive,
ridiculously aggressive shit.
Luck.
Even as a champion,
he might not land it,
but dude,
he knocked Melvin man who have dead.
It's crazy.
He's so indestructable we're
man Hook was 10 off on you.
You treat them like a reaction,
like a geode just kicking his leg.
His leg looked like it
was like a like on a,
on a string like war.
And then he just talked to his head.
I'll give Wonderboy the title shot.
Well I believe so.
I believe so,
but I,
I,
I think the Tyron Woodley still has a
real good argument that he deserves the
title shot even though he's
not as impressive as this
guy because his last fight
he won by injury.
You know,
Carlos condit kicked fucked up as me.
He was,
he was winning that fight though.
He definitely wanted the first graph.
That's a tough argument,
especially as far as mark and bill saying
that he was supposed to be fighting
Johny Hendricks number one title shot.
Johnny Hendricks had to pull out because
he didn't make weight and essentially
Tyron was promised the title shot.
You know how the PFC rose thing?
I don't think it's a bad
thing if Wonderboy weights
out and knock somebody else
off because I'm telling you
my performance like this,
a performance like this is like
some superstar emerging shit.
Dude.
He looked like a genius tonight.
A striking genius.
Look at that spinning
back kick to the arm.
Like it's like getting hit by
a fucking bat in your arms.
He's kicking him in the arms.
Johnny Hendricks was like,
what the fuck?
Getting hit by a machine.
Oh my God,
everything he's doing is perfect example.
This is a direct example of what we were
talking about when we were going over
the technique of the kick.
He throws everything,
he slides into it,
he turns his hip over,
he turns his hip over
and he throws punches.
He's laser beam accurate man,
like he's on a wire and sees what
you're doing before you do it right.
See all you're going to throw it,
write it,
and let me just,
let me just move a little bit back.
But by the way,
he landed that right kick to the body.
They're white kick to the body and that
exchange before it was extraordinary
because he's,
he knows he's on the way out,
but he also knows where Hendricks left
arm is and he sneaks that right kick
right under it as he
was sliding backwards,
which very few people are
going to be able to do crazy.
You know the crazy guy
took my fighting more.
So what you do in martial arts,
you,
like I said before,
we all have a certain
amount of time to drill,
so whatever.
What ever the cold food,
the karate guys,
whatever they were doing during the dark
ages when we thought it didn't work,
whatever they were doing,
they were getting really good at it,
at that range and getting
fucking the best at that range.
Maybe they can get taken down easily.
Maybe though they don't know any Jujitsu.
But now we gotten to the point where they
spent all that time in that range and
now they added in supplement a wrestling
so they can stay in that range.
The range that they rule,
the range that they spent all their time
and the range that nobody else spent
that much time on that ranch.
But they got the wrestling
and the surroundings,
they can stay in that range that they
rule in during the dark ages when everyone
thought that didn't work,
but hey,
guess what?
Now we're the fucking works.
Cause I got all that shit.
I love heavy.
We just saw karate when he talks.
He talks.
He's like,
dude,
we have to end this podcast on that.
Cause we have
mark,
we're at the three hour mark.
We,
we did we go over yet?
But yeah,
we have swapped,
slightly went over three hours.
So most of this has gone good.
I'd everybody good long,
big kiss.
Eddie,
you're grabbing me ramble.
No,
you're great.
Could you go when it gets dark.